mes chers collègues nous allons
commencer
voilà je suis heureux d'accueillir en
votre nom ce matin Monsieur Jacques
Rivoal président et Monsieur Julien
Colette directeur général
du groupement d'intérêts publics France
2023 chargez vous le savez d'organiser
la Coupe du monde de rugby
en France du 8 septembre au 28 octobre
prochain cette Coupe du Monde est
souvent considérée comme une répétition
générale avant le début des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de Paris
2024 et ce sera effectivement le dernier
événement d'ampleur qui sera organisée
sur l'ensemble du territoire avant
l'accueil de la plus grande compétition
sportive mondiale pourtant il serait
très réducteur et même un juste de
ramener cette Coupe du monde à une
simple mise en jambe vous voyez je vous
rassure tout de suite parce que vous
avez été inquiété par mes premiers
propos
cette manifestation
cette manifestation constitue un
événement international de premier rang
qui devrait
même certains qui passionnera des
centaines de millions de téléspectateurs
et rassemblera des centaines de milliers
de spectateurs le rugby bénéficie en
effet d'un réel engouement comme
l'illustre les audiences du Top 14 et du
Tournoi des 6 Nations
même quand l'équipe de France
ou perd comme samedi dernier mais c'est
ainsi la loi du sport un peu plus de 6
mois de cet événement nous souhaitions
donc faire le point avec vous messieurs
sur les différents aspects de
l'organisation de cet événement où en
sont les préparatifs concernant les neuf
stades prévus pour la compétition les
plans de transport les dispositifs de
sécurité concernant les recettes
générées par cet événement où on est de
vous en termes de billetterie et de
sponsor au delà de ces questions
habituelles à l'approche d'une grande
manifestation sportive nous sommes
également obligés de vous interroger sur
la gouvernance du GIP France 2023 dont
je rappelle qu'il est détenu à 67% par
la Fédération française de rugby par 37%
par l'État et 1% par le cnewsf en
septembre dernier le directeur général
Claudette cher a été écarté de ses
responsabilités au motif que son
management n'était pas
l'exemple d'une certaine brutalité que
de nombreuses zigues irrégularités
avaient été commises
notre commission n'a pas pour rôle de se
substituer aux enquêtes en cours sur ces
irrégularités toutefois dans le cadre de
ces missions de contrôle elle est
compétente pour établir des faits et
assurer la transparence dans les
domaines qui relèvent de ces missions
nous souhaitons donc dans ces conditions
que vous nous expliquer les difficultés
auxquelles vous avez dû faire face à
l'issue du départ du précédent directeur
général et plus particulièrement les
risques pesant sur l'organisation de la
Coupe du monde de rugby certaines
informations ayant laissé entendre ayant
laissé entendre pardon que l'équilibre
économique de la manifestation pourrait
être moins favorable qu'initialement
annoncé monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Directeur général je vais vous
laisser la parole pour un propos
liminaire après quoi je proposerai à
notre rapporteur pour les crédits du
sport Jean-Jacques Lauzac et au
président du groupe d'études sur le
sport et les grands événements sportifs
Michel Savin de vous premier de vous
poser une première série de questions et
je ne doute pas que à l'issue de ces
premières questions il y en aura
d'autres posées par mes collègues avant
de vous donner la parole monsieur le
Président je rappelle que cette audition
est captée et diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat messieurs je sais
la parole
bien merci merci monsieur le Président
donc on va on a prévu de vous faire un
petit exposé introductif là et bien sûr
surtout de répondre à toutes les
questions que vous souhaiterez nous
poser donc comme vous l'avez mentionné
donc depuis l'été on a mis en place une
gouvernance collégiale au sein du git
donc avec Julien Colette qui est le
directeur général on vous fera cette
présentation un peu à demain alors
quelques généralités sur sur la Coupe du
monde alors effectivement la Coupe du
monde de rugby c'est le troisième grand
événement sportif alors on parle
beaucoup de la même mentionné des Jeux
Olympiques auront lieu en 2024 mais on
est très fier de dire la Coupe du monde
de rugby après les Jeux Olympiques et la
coupe du monde de foot c'est l'événement
le grand événement sportif le plus
important donc dans le monde alors le
rugby
c'est un sport qui a le vent le vent en
poupe aujourd'hui c'est un sport qui est
en pleine essor
avec une un sport qui était anglo-saxon
à l'origine mais maintenant qui
généralise un peu dans tous les pays à
128 pays qui pratiquent ce beau sport un
sport qui se féminise aujourd'hui
l'augmentation des licenciés en
particulier en France il vient de
l'apport des des filles et des jeunes
femmes qui qui découvrent ce sport qui
peut être aussi un sport féminin et puis
donc il y a plus de 800 millions de fans
qui suivent de te téléspectateurs qui
suivent les matchs de rugby dans le
monde alors on a fait une enquête
également sur sur la France avec auprès
d'un panel de spectateurs de femmes et
les gens apprécient le rugby 80% des
Français sont favorables à
l'organisation d'une coupe du monde de
rugby donc c'est important les les
Français soutiennent l'événement parce
qu'il considère à hauteur de 90% que cet
événement aura des retombées positives
pour pour le pays et en plus qui nous a
effectivement étonné c'est que les trois
quarts des Français souhaitent
participer à l'événement donc soit en
étant dans les stades soit en suivant
les compétitions derrière devant leur
écran
alors ensuite
on a la chance d'avoir une équipe de
France effectivement qui est assez
brillante en ce moment et pour nous le
le
l'objectif majeur d'une Coupe du Monde
c'est vraiment de faire une grande fête
alors on a pris un terme plus plus
générique que celui-là qui est le terme
de célébration mais c'est vraiment sous
ce mot-là que l'on veut organiser
l'événement c'est une grande fête
populaire qui va se dérouler pendant 51
jours et qui va être dans tous les
territoires de France et donc on espère
qu'on pourra effectivement construire
des grands moments d'événements sportifs
alors la compétition
au niveau du plateau sportif va être
exceptionnel puisqu'on va avoir les les
20 équipes de rugby dans le monde qui
seront qui vont s'affronter pendant 51
jours donc c'est c'est 660 joueurs soit
660 joueurs qui seront réunis 20 nations
qualifiées et on pense qu'on aura un
plateau sportif tout à fait exceptionnel
parce qu'en fait les cartes
les cartes ont été vraiment rebattues
aujourd'hui au niveau du rugby mondial
le premier pays c'est l'Irlande et on a
bien sûr les grands pays du Sud
l'Australie la Nouvelle-Zélande
l'Afrique du Sud mais il y a des
nouveaux pays qui émergent dans le monde
du rugby comme la Géorgie comme pour la
première fois le Chili qui va participer
à sa première à sa première Coupe du
Monde il y aura trois pays du d'Amérique
du Sud qui seront présents avec le Chili
l'Argentine et l'Uruguay donc un sport
qui se un plateau sportif qui va être
tout à fait exceptionnel alors le
calendrier
pour ceux qui ne le connaissent pas donc
il y a d'abord des matchs de poules il y
a quatre poules qui réunissent 5 équipes
alors la particularité d'une coupe du
monde de rugby c'est que c'est pas un
événement parisien pour pour apify ou un
c'est vraiment un événement qui se
déroulera dans dans neuf stades dans les
grandes villes de province donc il y a
d'abord les les cinq les quatre matchs
de poules et ensuite il y a des quarts
de finale des demi-finales et la finale
et ainsi que la petite finale de bronze
qui aura lieu au Stade de France
[Musique]
alors la fête la célébration pourquoi
c'est parce qu'effectivement l'événement
il va être complètement national encore
une fois les les stades je les citerai
tout à l'heure mais c'est les grandes
villes de France et donc on considère
qu'à peu près alors à part l'est de la
France l'Alsace la Lorraine la Bourgogne
et la frange comté mais on peut
considérer qu'aujourd'hui 80% de la
population française sera à moins de
deux heures d'un site de compétition
alors il y aura les neufs les neuf
stades où se déroulant les compétitions
mais il y a également les camps de base
donc il y a 20 camps de base plus les
bases quand de match va le site de match
donc en fait c'est une cinquantaine de
villes qui auront le plaisir
d'accueillir également les équipes
pendant entre les matchs donc 10 vélos
je l'ai mentionné et neuf neuf stade
haute
alors les stades vous les avez sur le
slide suivant donc la compétition ça
démarre le 8 septembre jusqu'au 28
octobre donc c'est une compétition qui
est longue ça dure pratiquement deux
mois 10 vélos de 51 jours de fête et
donc vous avez ici et donc on l'a de
façon plus détaillée après voilà les
différents stades qui vont accueillir
les compétitions donc on aura Lille
Saint-Denis alors Paris on considère que
c'était également une ville haute parce
qu'il y aura des des
le centre de presse le broadcast etc qui
seront basés à Paris ensuite il y a
Nantes Bordeaux Toulouse Marseille -
Nice Saint-Étienne et Lyon
[Musique]
voilà Mappy alors après j'étais passé la
parole maintenant à Julien pour
détailler les d'autres sujets
les rapporteur mesdames c'est natrice
Monsieur les sénateurs très heureux de
venir rapporter de vous au sujet de
l'organisation de cette Coupe du Monde
président me donne l'occasion
après ce slide sur les les stades les
neuf stades qui vont accueillir la
compétition peut-être de faire un
éclairage sur l'économie de l'événement
puisque le président Laffont nous
attendu cette perche en introduction Les
et c'est venu sur la table effectivement
lors du changement de gouvernance nous
sortons d'une revue budgétaire complète
qui a montré que lorsque l'on compare le
niveau de dépenses d'exploitation
nécessaire à l'organisation de cet
événement au standard internationaux
nous sommes en train d'organiser le
président aiguë le rappelait le
troisième événement sportif mondial avec
près d'un milliard de téléspectateurs
qui sera alors peu importe la répétition
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques ou
pas la répétition peu importe mais en
tout cas qui sera sous les lumières du
monde entier on ne peut pas le faire à
un niveau de dépense inférieur à celui
de nos prédécesseurs sauf à considérer
que les Japonais les Anglais étaient
absolument incompétents en matière
d'organisation d'événements ce qui n'est
évidemment pas le cas or le niveau de
dépenses moyen pour l'organisation des
précédentes Coupe du monde étaient
autour de 250 millions d'euros il était
prévu avant la revue budgétaire un
niveau de dépenses inférieur à 200
millions d'euros qui mettaient en danger
qui mettait en risque le niveau de
qualité d'organisation de l'événement
donc il était de notre responsabilité en
relation extrêmement étroite avec l'État
et avec World rugby ainsi qu'avec la
Fédération française de rugby de revoir
ce niveau de dépenses non seulement pour
prendre en compte l'effet inflationniste
que vous connaissez tous qui impacte
l'ensemble des métiers qui sont aussi
les nôtres mais aussi simplement
de mettre en cohérence notre niveau de
dépenses avec nos obligations en termes
d'organisation de cet événement à la
fois nos obligations contractuelles à
l'égard World rugby et de l'État mais
aussi nos engagements notamment en
termes de responsabilité sociale et
environnementale et en termes d'héritage
donc aujourd'hui après au budgétaire
nous arrivons à un niveau de dépenses de
215 millions d'euros plus une réserve de
3 millions d'euros qui est certes
limitée mais les 215 millions d'euros de
dépenses auxquelles nous parvenons
inclut déjà les effets de l'inflation
puisque nous sommes aujourd'hui à moins
de 7 mois d'événement et que nous
connaissons les prix auxquels nous
allons acheter la plupart des
prestations et auxquelles bien entendu
nous embauchons nos salariés sachant que
99 millions d'euros restent à engagés
enfin sont à engager sur cette année
on viendra plus tard sur la partie
recette mais parmi et ça fera la
transition avec le reste de cette
présentation parmi les dépenses qui sont
importantes et qui avaient été en partie
sous-estimé par choix par choix de
considérer que l'État et les
collectivités locales aller assurer des
dépenses qui leur incombaient pas
forcément en termes de sécurité nous
avons
évidemment travailler de manière étroite
avec notre directeur de la sécurité qui
à ma droite Olivier d'un prêt avec les
services de l'État avec la CNJ avec le
ministère de l'intérieur avec les
digestes et les dix Jobs à revoir les
dispositifs de sécurité et assurer lors
conformité à la fois nos obligations et
aussi leur adeptabilité au contexte
locaux à la situation de chaque stade et
à la situation de chaque camp de base
le second élément c'est que pour assurer
la meilleure sécurité de cet événement
il faut intégrer la sécurité à la
qualité des parcours clients et des
parcours spectateurs et non pas la
considérer comme
une politique à part vivant sa vie en
dehors de l'organisation d'événements la
clé c'est que tout au long du parcours
spectateur c'est-à-dire du départ d'un
tétonteur de billets depuis l'aéroport
de sa ville de sa ville de résidence à
l'autre bout du monde dans l'hémisphère
sud ou depuis Londres en Eurostar qu'il
puisse sentir que la sécurité
est assurée de la meilleure manière
notamment par le fait qu'on puisse
communiquer avec lui de manière très
étroite et de ce point de vue là le
choix stratégique qui a été fait dès le
départ de maîtriser l'ensemble du
processus de commercialisation et de
gestion de la billetterie par un système
qui nous permet
de détenir les données de tous nos
clients de tous nos détenteurs de
billets et donc de pouvoir communiquer
avec eux puisque ces clients
naturellement qui nous laisse l'usage de
leur donner puisqu'il considère
quand ils achètent un billet ils font un
achat loisirs ils font un achat plaisir
et donc ils ont confiance dans la
personne qui organise l'événement il
n'achète pas un réfrigérateur à qui est
avec la réticence à donner des des leurs
données à un opérateur industriel qu'il
ne connaissent pas donc cette force qui
nous permet d'exploiter les données
clients d'un million de personnes nous
permet aussi de communiquer avec eux et
de les intégrer finalement à notre
dispositif de de sécurisation
les dispositifs comme je le disais vont
être adaptés à chaque contexte local
dans le cadre de d'étude de sûreté
notamment liés à chaque camp de base au
vin camp de base on y reviendra
l'enjeu aujourd'hui pour nous il est de
finaliser la possession des contrats de
des marchés de sécurité privée dans le
cadre de marchés publics puisque nous
sommes soumis naturellement droit de la
commande publique nous devons déployer
6300 agents de sécurité privée sur les 9
sites de compétition un peu au-delà si
on compte les camps de base
à part deux ou trois sites un peu en
tension mais qui ne nous inquiète pas
outre mesure il faut savoir
que le pic de mobilisation d'agents de
sécurité privée sur un week-end
organisation de la Coupe du Monde
correspond à un week-end de match de
Ligue 1
donc le marché de la sécurité privée
aujourd'hui en France et en mesure de
répondre à nos besoins à la fois en
qualité et en quantité d'agents sachant
encore une fois que la compétition a
lieu pendant l'automne qu'elle n'a pas
lieu en plein cœur de l'été et qui a des
réparties sur 9 sites différentes
compétitions d'ici au total avec la
Ville de Paris qui accueille des
fonctions essentielles à l'organisation
d'événements donc on a besoin de
concentrer comme ça peut être le cas des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
concentrer
un nombre extrêmement important d'agents
de sécurité sur une sur une seule région
pendant une période estivale
pour le reste le point clé en matière de
sécurité c'est la coordination avec les
acteurs et non seulement avec les
acteurs avec les forces de sécurité
intérieure naturellement et dans ce
cadre là nous nous fonctionnons
d'un partenariat avec le ministère de
l'intérieur d'une convention de
partenariat avec le ministère de
l'intérieur mais aussi avec les autres
acteurs concernés qui sont les
opérateurs de transport en particulier
et les collectivités locales les
autorités organisent les transports au
niveau des collectivités des métropoles
et ce point est clé pour la gestion des
flux et la fluidité de la gestion des
flux autour des stades en amont des
matchs et après les matchs
nous reviendrons bien évidemment sur les
questions de sécurité si vous le
souhaitez plus tard une priorité de
l'organisation de l'événement pour la
Fédération internationale de rugby pour
avoir le rugby qui explique aussi la
durée de l'événement les 51 jours
qui qui sont mobilisés pour organiser
les 48 matchs c'est la santé des joueurs
la santé des joueurs le respect de la
santé des joueurs exige 5 jours de repos
pour toutes les équipes durant la
compétition
ce qui nous a amenés à prolonger
en fait à intensifier le nombre de jours
de repos de manière significative par
rapport aux précédentes éditions de la
Coupe du monde puisque comme vous le
voyez que ce soit en Angleterre au Pays
de Galles en 2015 ou au Japon en 2019 le
nombre de jours de repos était inférieur
à 340 et il va être
supérieur d'une centaine pour l'édition
de notre coupe du monde avec 33 joueurs
mobilisés pour chaque équipe au lieu de
31 dans au cours des éditions
précédentes en matière de revenus la
commercialisation de la billetterie à
rencontrer un succès qu'on peut
qualifier de phénoménal c'est-à-dire que
les billets se sont si vous passez
l'expression se sont vraiment arrachés
comme des petits pains
aujourd'hui les 2,2 millions de billets
réservés réservé au grand public sont
tous vendus nous avons mis en ligne au
mois de au mois de janvier une
plateforme officielle de revente de la
billetterie qui est le seul canal par
lequel
légalement les détenteurs de billets
peuvent revendre leur billet et ce au
prix facial d'achat plus l'application
d'une d'une participation frais de 10%
du prix facial d'achat
sachant que nous développons en
parallèle une politique de lutte contre
le marché noir en particulier de
surveillance des plateformes comme
viagogo avec laquais contre laquelle
nous venons d'obtenir une décision de
justice d'ailleurs favorable
mais aussi contre toutes les plateformes
internet qui autoriseraient des
détenteurs de billets à essayer de
revendre leurs billets à des prix
supérieurs au prix au prix facial et en
tout cas de manière par un autre canal
que la plateforme officielle de revente
la billetterie c'est la principale
source de nos revenus nous avons encore
une fois
à peu près 400 millions d'euros à
couvrir de dépenses les 218 millions
d'euros de dépenses d'exploitation dont
je parlais et puis le reste est en
constitué des droits que nous achetons à
worldogue bi pour organiser la Coupe du
monde
et
la billetterie représente au terme de
notre dernière revue budgétaire 347
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
donc c'est la clé
évidemment c'est la clé de la création
de valeur dans l'organisation de cette
Coupe du monde à la fois en termes de
revenus et aussi en termes
d'expérience spectateurs et
d'enrichissement de cette expérience
spectateur
comme je le disais le fait que nous
maîtrisions cette billetterie nous
permet de connaître parfaitement le
public qui a acheté des billets et comme
vous le voyez sur
sur cette diapositive mais bien entendu
nous diffuserons cette présentation nous
pouvons nous connaissons parfaitement la
répartition des acheteurs par genre
alors il se trouve que le public rugby
reste très masculin mais comme le disait
Jacques rivol en introduction il y a de
plus en plus de jeunes femmes qui
pratiquent le rugby donc
la féminisation est en cours est
accéléré mais ça reste un public très
masculin en revanche et ça c'est plutôt
une bonne surprise pour nous
contrairement à l'audience des matchs du
des matchs du 15 de France que les
diffuseurs nous donnent qui est
âgé
qui est en moyenne dans la majorité
constituée
de plus de 40 ans nous avons aujourd'hui
une majorité comme vous le voyez une
majorité de détenteurs de billets qui
ont moins de 40 ans ce qui est plutôt
extrêmement positif et une très bonne
nouvelle à tout point de vue à la fois
pour le renouvellement du public et
aussi bien entendu pour en matière de de
participation de ce public à la vie de
l'événement et plus généralement à
l'animation du territoire
la réponse nous connaissons
naturellement la provenance des
acheteurs de billets comme vous le voyez
comme vous le voyez sur cette
diapositive
la répartie
heureusement plus de la moitié des
spectateurs sont français donc on peut
penser que les stades vont vibrer au son
de la au son de la Marseillaise de
manière très forte et c'est important
mais les Anglais les Irlandais les
Britanniques en général ont acheté
beaucoup de billets ils sont évidemment
très fans de rugby comme vous le savez
l'Angleterre est quand même le berceau
de ce sport dont on va fêter d'ailleurs
le bicentenaire cette année
et donc ce sont parmi les 40%
d'acheteurs de billets qui viennent de
l'étranger
60% viennent des îles britanniques le
reste se répartissant de manière
c'est marginale mais entre beaucoup de
pays dont des pays bien entendu de les
ministère Sud
concernant la répartition géographique
des acheteurs français par région ou par
département d'ailleurs du territoire de
manière
peu surprenantes les Toulousains vont
venir en force dans les stades mais
aussi mais aussi les Parisiens les
Girondins et au-delà de ça ce qui est
intéressant de constater à la lecture de
ce graphique c'est que le rugby n'est
plus seulement un sport du Sud-Ouest et
de la région parisienne
mais rayonne bien au-delà
sénateur ça va constatera notamment que
l'Isère est bien placé mais pas
seulement puisque
[Musique]
de manière un peu plus surprenante la
loi Atlantique la loi Atlantique ou le
Nord sont également des portsvoyeurs de
fans de manière importante parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y a des stades c'est
vrai qu'il y a des stades mais ça montre
qu'il y a des fans de l'équipe de France
de rugby et au delà dans ces
départements de manière forte donc
aujourd'hui ce sport est en plein essor
sur tout le territoire il faut le noter
avec une exception notable qui reste le
grand est une terre de mission pour le
rugby à tout point de vue
en matière de sponsoring
là encore comment billetterie
cette coupe du monde va être une coupe
du monde de records en termes de
recettes de sponsoring non seulement de
recettes de sponsoring avec environ 80
millions d'euros de recettes de deux
chiffres d'affaires liés à la vente de
contrat de partenariat mais aussi en
termes de diversité des acteurs
économiques qui ont choisi de soutenir
la Coupe du monde les partenaires
majeurs que vous voyez les cinq
partenaires majeurs sont des partenaires
de World rugby donc qui ne sont pas en
contrat directement avec nous mais qui
peuvent nous apporter
du support direct notamment du support
nature comme Capgemini qui est un leader
français mais mondial dans son dans ces
métiers et qui nous aide beaucoup en
termes de système d'information de
gestion de nos systèmes d'information
mais au-delà de ça comme vous le voyez
beaucoup de nos sponsors principaux tous
d'ailleurs de tous nos sponsors
principaux les sponsors officiels sont
des entreprises françaises leaders
iment chacune dans leur secteur
d'activités et dans des secteurs très
diversifiés qui vont des services
publics comme la SNCF
jusqu'au métier de l'entertainment avec
Vivendi où les télécommunications avec
Orange et puis des
GMF qui a un sponsor historique du rugby
où gly27 Loxam qui sont des prestataires
importants du secteur de l'organisation
événementielle
quelques mots rapidement aujourd'hui
notre enjeu dans les six mois qui
viennent c'est de faire monter l'envie
de faire monter l'envie parmi la
population parmi
l'ensemble des acteurs aussi économiques
et sociaux pour cette Coupe du monde
avec un slogan célébrons toutes les
fraternités qui résonnent avec la devise
républicaine mais non seulement avec la
devise républicaine mais aussi avec les
valeurs du rugby ce qui évidemment est
fondamental et qui a une transcription
anglaise qui fonctionne aussi très bien
donc ce célébrons toutes les fraternités
va être déclinée dans toutes nos
communications dans les six mois qui
viennent à tous les niveaux et en
partenariat notamment avec les
collectivités territoriales avec trois
objectifs c'est faire monter
l'engouement c'est construire un vrai
lien de confiance avec le public
notamment autour de la sécurité on en
parlait tout à l'heure mais au-delà
autour du fait que les valeurs
véhiculées par la marque coupe du monde
de rugby résonne avec celle de la
population en général et de ce point de
vue pour rebondir sur ce que disait le
président Lafont l'introduction les
affres qu'on traverse la gouvernance de
du comité d'organisation et la
gouvernance de rugby français en général
d'ailleurs non pas peser du tout sur
l'image de marque de la Coupe du monde
de rugby il y a comme à l'habitude de
lire Jacques Rival la marque est très
forte la marque coupe du monde de rugby
est très forte et aujourd'hui à une
image extrêmement positive qui n'est pas
atteinte parce que peuvent connaître
la Fédération française de rugby ou ce
qui a pu connaître le comité
d'organisation mais dans sa gouvernance
uniquement interne et enfin nous voulons
créer un sentiment d'impatience et de ce
point de vue là nous vous donnons
notamment rendez-vous lors du J-100 à la
fin mai qui sera un grand moment de
célébration de la Coupe du monde de
rugby sur tout le territoire
et la force de cet événement et c'est ce
qui a fait aujourd'hui que World rugby a
choisi la France pour organiser en 2016
pour organiser la Coupe du monde en 2023
c'est que c'est une coupe du monde des
territoires nous y associons non
seulement les 10 les 10 métropoles et
villes hautes mais
une majorité de région qui sont très
investies en particulier les régions
Occitanie ou elle Aquitaine Sud
Île-de-France haute France Pays de la
Loire
et d'autres mais celle-ci sont
particulièrement investies et beaucoup
de départements et toutes les
collectivités porteurs de projets des
camps de base et des bassides de matchs
et elles sont nombreuses
notamment les 20 villes qui accueillent
des camps de base qui vont donner une
image importante de la France pour les
équipes qui sont accueillies sur le
territoire
l'un des succès l'adhésion de du public
à cette Coupe du Monde on l'a notamment
observer de manière forte lors de la
circulation du train du rugby entre
juillet et novembre dernier grâce à
notre partenariat avec la SNCF 51 villes
ont été visitées 100000 visiteurs
et quand on dit 100000 visiteurs c'est
vraiment des des visiteurs qui ont passé
du temps dans le train ou sur les
villages du train donc ce sont des
visiteurs qui ont des fans vraiment de
rugby qui sont venus
sur à l'occasion de ce passage du train
sur tout le territoire français
l'autre manière de faire adhérer les
territoires ce sont ces 20 camps de base
qui vont nous permettre aussi
d'ouvrir de faire connaître le rugby à
des populations qui n'ont pas accès au
stade notamment par l'organisation
d'entraînement ouvert au public
au moins un entraînement ouvert au
public sera organisé sur chaque camp de
base et pour beaucoup d'autres équipes
dont les équipes les moins majeurs que
certaines
qui ont un nom juste sportif moins
important donc que d'autres cette ce
lien avec le public va être très
important et donc ces équipes vont avoir
à coeur de créer un lien très fort avec
la population locale par des
entraînements ouverts au public comme
vous le voyez on a essayé de répartir
les camps de base de manière équilibrée
sur le territoire
[Musique]
parfois il faut le dire en forçant un
peu la main des équipes mais c'était
important pour nous que on puisse que
les équipes puissent vraiment être
présent dans un maximum de régions et
pouvoir nouer un lien avec le maximum de
clubs amateurs notamment et d'écoles de
rugby
dans les villes et les métropoles hautes
l'un des lieux de célébration majeurs de
la Coupe du Monde sera ce qu'on n'a pas
appelé la Fan Zone comme on le fait dans
d'autres sports mais ce qu'on va appeler
les villages de rugby donc et qui vont
réunir pouvoir réunir au moins 10000
personnes dans les centres dans les
centres des grandes agglomérations qui
accueillent les matchs plus Paris qui
accueille des fonctions majeures
d'organisation du tournoi sachant que la
Fan Zone parisienne sera
organisée sur un lieu iconique la place
de la Concorde un peu en prélude des
manifestations liées à la célébration
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
nous restons en discussion comme vous le
constatez avec la métropole européenne
de Lille pour trouver une solution que
nous n'avons pas encore trouvé sur le
territoire de la métropole européenne de
Lille mais nous ne perdons pas espoir
et en parallèle
pour permettre à toutes les
collectivités à tous les clubs amateurs
de pouvoir célébrer la Coupe du monde
sans avoir à rentrer dans le carcan de
la protection des droits commerciaux
puisque un grand événement comme ça
dans le cadre de l'organisation d'un
grand événement comme ça la Fédération
internationale de manière moins à moins
stricte que le CIO pour les Jeux
Olympiques et Paralympiques mais malgré
tout exercent une surveillance très
stricte
de ses droits commerciaux et de leur de
leur respect et donc pour éviter
d'avoir à faire survivre ces contraintes
à tous les acteurs qui voudraient
célébrer la Coupe du monde de rugby nous
avons créé un label qui s'appelle le
rugby festival qui va être lancé très
prochainement au travers d'une
plateforme internet qui permettra aux
porteur de projets de tout simplement
d'y adhérer un pas de se porter candidat
nous sommes nous ne sommes pas là pour
les sélectionner mais pour simplement
permettre à tous ceux et toutes celles
qui veulent créer un événement autour de
la Coupe du Monde de le faire en
utilisant pas la marque Coupe du monde
mais en utilisant cette marque rugby
festival
et puis cette coupe du monde doit être
aussi et c'est important pour nous une
coupe du monde avec un impact positif
quand on dit un impact positif ne nous
racontons pas d'histoire organiser un
événement majeur de ce type là avec 2
millions 500 000 détenteurs de billets
qui viennent du monde entier pour 600
000 d'entre eux
général des émissions notamment de gaz
carbonique on ne sait pas transporter
des équipes sportives et on ne sait pas
transporter des spectateurs de
l'hémisphère sud sans émettre sans les
en dehors de l'avion en revanche
on a fait le choix
d'investir dans des programmes
d'absorption du carbone
et c'est une innovation parce que ça
n'avait jamais été fait dans le cadre
d'organisation de la Coupe du monde
en partenariat d'ailleurs avec les
collectivités locales et avec des
partenaires économiques nous avons fait
le choix aussi
d'investir fortement dans l'économie
durable et circulaire notamment dans la
gestion de nos services de restauration
au grand public et pas seulement au
grand public aussi aux VIP puisque nous
allons nourrir
2 millions 600 mille spectateurs plus
tous les organisateurs avec des
opérateurs qui vont privilégier les
filières courtes de production et
locales et qui vont aussi privilégier
la lutte contre le gaspillage
alimentaire et de ce point de vue là
nous avons nous un partenariat avec les
banques alimentaires
ainsi que
le recyclage des déchets
et l'autre
pilier majeur de notre politique à ceux
de notre stratégie RSE concerne
l'engagement en faveur de l'éducation de
la formation et de l'emploi et de ce
point de vue là de manière extrêmement
innovante très originale et c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire d'un grand
événement sportif international que ça a
lieu le comité d'organisation a créé en
partenariat avec l'État et les
partenaires sociaux un CFA d'entreprise
qui s'appelle campus 2023 et qui permet
la formation de 1427 jeunes sur tout le
territoire qui seront en septembre qui
seront à la fin de l'année tous diplômés
et qui ont participé à l'organisation de
la Coupe du Monde au préalable dans le
cadre d'un
programme immersif sachant que 500 de
ses emplois ont la garanti d'être
pérennisé grâce à des aides de l'Agence
nationale du sport et
de France 2023 via son bénéfice
d'exploitation et nous allons aider les
autres à trouver des emplois notamment
pour l'organisation des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques voilà je crois que le
président Lafont en train de me gronder
donc je vais
m'arrêter là nous avons aussi un fond de
dotation qui soutient beaucoup d'actions
locales et beaucoup de clubs et
naturellement nous sommes à votre
disposition pour répondre à toutes vos
questions merci merci en tout cas déjà
pour ces réponses enfin pour ces
éléments très précis et ces informations
que vous nous avez données je j'imagine
que ça soulève un certain nombre de
questions et sans plus tarder je vais
donner la parole à Jean-Jacques Lauzac
et rapporteur pour avis du budget sport
et dans la foulée à Michel ça va qui
préside le groupe d'études grands
événements sportifs Jean-Jacques bien
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Président et Monsieur
directeur général du GIP mondial rugby
pour cette pour cette présentation
je commencerai par une question sur la
sécurité parce que malheureusement j'ai
envie de dire aujourd'hui on ne peut
plus parler de d'organisation de grands
événements sportifs international sans
évoquer cette question de la sécurité et
vous savez qu'on sort d'un débat ici
concernant le texte de jeux olympiques
et paralympique qui a été
essentiellement sécuritaire et avec des
dispositions qui vont d'abord concerner
la Coupe du monde de rugby
chronologiquement avant l'organisation
des Jeux Olympiques et
paralympique alors bien sûr on connaît
pas le texte définitif puisqu'il est
toujours pas passé à l'Assemblée
nationale mais j'aurais savoir quel est
le regard quelle est l'analyse que vous
faites d'ores et déjà du texte tel qu'il
est sorti de nos débats sénatoriaux tout
en sachant que derrière cette
problématique de la sécurité se pose
notamment la question de la relation
entre les organisateurs et puis les
supporters plus ou moins organisés alors
j'ai vu qu'il y avait notamment des par
exemple une amicale des supporters du 15
de France une association des supporters
du XV de France etc je voudrais savoir
si ce type de ce type de structuration
de supporters ont été associés à la
préparation de cet événement
deuxièmement bien évidemment
aujourd'hui je dis pas ce qui domine
parce qu'il faut surtout pas généraliser
mais le sport français quand même
traversé par tout un ensemble de crises
de gouvernance auquel le rugby n'a pas
échappé c'est vrai du côté de la
Fédération française de rugby parce que
c'est quand même
rarissime c'est quand même exceptionnel
de voir en France un président de
fédération sportive démissionné
donc c'est tout à fait rarissime et la
Fédération représente cela a été rappelé
tout à l'heure les deux tiers de l'axe
ovaria du GIP donc nous bien sûr on vit
ça de l'extérieur mais on a du on est un
petit peu de mal à reprendre ce que ce
qui a été dit tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire que tu aurais eu aucun
impact sur la préparation de la Coupe du
monde de rugby de cette de cette crise
de gouvernance et puis en lien avec ce
que je viens de dire j'ai vu dans votre
vous avez un comité d'éthique
et je voudrais savoir si effectivement
ce comité d'éthique a été associé s'est
réuni au cours de ces de ces derniers
mois au cours de ces dernières années
parce que je crois qu'on est un certain
nombre à souhaiter justement davantage
de responsabilité davantage de
prérogative au sein de ces comités
d'éthique interne à telle ou tel
fédération ou à tel ou tel structure qui
organise des événements de cette
importance alors par ailleurs une
question sur l'héritage parce qu'on
parle beaucoup d'héritage olympique mais
je crois que maintenant pour chaque
grand événement sportif on sera amené à
parler de l'héritage et je voudrais
savoir que ce que vous attendez en terme
d'héritage même si vous l'avez plus ou
moins abordé tout à l'heure
ce que vous avez débuté votre propos en
disant que le
rugby se portait de mieux en mieux je
dirais sur le plan mondial c'est vrai
mais sur le plan national c'est pas tout
à fait vrai puisque il y a une baisse du
nombre de clubs et une baisse du nombre
de licenciés alors c'est vrai que le
covid est passé par là quoi
oui
on peut discuter des chiffres
avec un redémarrage maintenant mais
donc qu'attendez-vous justement en
termes d'héritage est-ce que vous sentez
une véritable mobilisation des clubs
derrière cette organisation et quand
j'ai d'héritage c'est notamment en
tenant compte de cette expérience qui
est qui était celle de 2007 puisque la
France est déjà organisée la Coupe du
monde de rugby en 2007 et enfin une
dernière question bon vous avez évoqué
la dimension budgétaire je n'y reviens
que très très partiellement
je voudrais savoir parce que vous l'avez
pas mentionné mais ce qu'apporte
effectivement World rugby financièrement
ou alors est-ce que c'est simplement le
sponsoring qui transite je dirais par
World de rugby et est-ce que vous avez
comme ça une estimation à la louche
puisqu'on est ici au Sénat maison des
collectivités des territoires est-ce que
vous avez une estimation à vous de ce
que les collectivités globalement vont
apporter à cette organisation notamment
mais pas simplement à travers les camps
de base merci ok très bien ben ez je
veux donner
merci monsieur le Président d'abord
remercier mais sur le président et
directeur général pour
l'exposé qui viennent de nous présenter
moi si je vais revenir sur deux points
qui aujourd'hui sont pour nous les plus
importants c'est bien sûr la sécurité
mais aussi l'habiller tri qui peut aussi
aujourd'hui nous interroger sur la
sécurité la première question elle est
un petit peu en lien avec celle qui
vient de poser Jean-Jacques Lauzac
la question c'est est-ce que avez-vous
l'intention de d'utiliser les moyens que
la loi olympique a été lors de son
dernier débat notamment sur
toutes les mesures qui sont liées à la
sécurité des personnes notamment la
vidéoprotection les caméras installées
sur les ronf sur les ainsi que les
véhicules et entre tout ce qui est aussi
la sécurité sur les véhicules et les
entreprises de transport public donc
quelles relations avez-vous parce que là
c'est pas un site c'est différente
villes qui sont concernées avec des
moyens de transport complètement
différents certains ont des métros
d'autres des transports par tram et
autres donc tout ça est-ce qu'il y a un
travail qui est fait spécifique par par
ville ou au niveau de la sécurité
deuxième point sur la sécurité
c'est ça concerne bien sûr vous avez
parlé des stades mais qu'en est-il des
camps de base mais aussi des fans est-ce
que les collectivités est-ce que c'est à
la charge de l'organisateur la sécurité
dans les fans mais aussi il y a des
lieux on sait qu'au niveau du rugby il y
a des lieux il y a la première et
deuxième mi-temps qui se passe sur le
stade et puis la troisième qui se passe
dans des lieux de rassemblement qui sont
bien identifiés dans certaines villes
est-ce qu'un travail est fait
spécifiquement en termes de sécurité au
lieu de ces autour de ces sites avec les
villes hautes troisièmement toujours sur
la sécurité
est-ce qu'il y a une partie qui est à la
charge des collectivités en termes de
sécurité notamment sur la sécurité
privée vous avez dit tout à l'heure que
vous n'irez pas normalement de problème
mais on sait que c'est quand même c'est
un métier qui est en tension les
sociétés de sécurité ont du mal à
recruter à former des personnels bon
c'est vrai que dans une période
peut-être plus propice et puis disperser
sur différents sites ce qui peut
permettre peut-être de pouvoir répondre
à votre appel d'offres donc où en est où
en est votre appel d'offres et comment
se situe cette organisation en termes de
sécurité
et puis sur notre maintenant sur la
billetterie
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter
parce qu'il y a eu la première vente qui
a été faite avec les paquets et puis les
grands publics aujourd'hui a été mis en
place sous votre responsabilité vous
allez confirmer la plateforme de revente
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter
cette plateforme de revente avec
Esca aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez
mis en place une sécurité contre la
fraude et le marché noir des billets qui
peut être potentiellement exil qui peut
potentiellement exister parce qu'on voit
que le nombre de billets a été très
largement vendu et donc quand il y a une
grosse demande il y a risque de fraude
et de marcher noir enfin
il avait été présenté au démarrage de
cette coupe du monde de rugby par la
Fédération Française de oui mais aussi
par les organisateurs de France 2023 que
certaines équipes même s'ils étaient
éliminés du premier tour restaurer en
France sur le territoire et
organiserait avec
les comités régionaux avec la Fédération
avec des collectivités des activités il
resterait la durée de la Coupe du monde
et que cette présence serait prise en
charge par la Fédération française de
rugby est-ce que c'est toujours
d'actualité est-ce que parce que ça a
été présenté et mis en avant lorsque les
communes les villes les métropoles ont
été candidates pour recevoir des camps
de base et c'est vrai le fait que de
recevoir certaines équipes et se dire
même si c'est une petite une équipe
entre guillemets
pas de première ordre mais qui peut
rester de la durée du tournoi ça va
créer une dynamique autour de du rugby
est-ce que c'est toujours d'actualité et
c'est intéressant de savoir où ces
équipes resteront et enfin dernier point
monsieur le Président toujours sur
l'héritage est-ce bien la Fédération
Française du rugby qui va gérer le
montant de l'héritage et qui va mettre
en place des actions auprès du rugby
amateur ou est-ce que c'est France 2023
qui va gérer de son côté cet héritage
merci
monsieur le Président alors on va se
répartir les réponses avec aussi Julien
bien sûr et Olivier d'impres qui est
notre responsable de la sécurité comme
on avait bien imaginé que vous auriez eu
vous allez avoir des questions sur la
sécurité on s'est dit qu'on allait
l'amener voilà parce que c'est lui
l'expert du sujet alors peut-être sur
déjà sur la sur la gouvernance donc il y
a deux sujets sur la gouvernance et
effectivement les problèmes de
gouvernance de la Fédération Française
de Rugby et les problèmes de gouvernance
spécifiques au GIP ou l'aviez monsieur
le Président mentionné dans dans
l'introduction avec les événements de
l'été qui nous ont amenés à
remplacer le directeur général précédent
alors donc sur la Fédération française
de rugby ce qu'il faut bien que les gens
comprennent parce que parfois c'est
c'est pas toujours très clair c'est
qu'en fait la préparation d'une coupe du
monde de rugby c'est la responsabilité
d'un comité d'organisation que je
préside dont le directeur général est
Julien Colette qui est une structure qui
a pris la forme juridique d'un GIP d'un
groupement d'un terrain public qui est
un comité finalement une structure
indépendante une entreprise en fait qui
prépare et qui travaille pour préparer
cet événement
dans lequel il y a effectivement trois
membres fondateurs il y a le Comité
national olympique sportif français pour
1% et surtout la Fédération française de
rugby pour 67% des droits de vote et
l'État pour 32% donc nous nos deux
actionnaires si on prend cette image en
fait principaux c'est l'état d'un côté
et la Fédération française de rugby donc
c'est vrai que il y a eu les affaires
que vous mentionnez depuis l'été
médiatico juridique sur la gouvernance
de la Fédération française de rugby mais
en fait qui sont des problèmes connexes
au comité d'organisation et qui
finalement n'ont pas impacté le comité
d'organisation puisque nous on a
continué à travailler les décisions
étaient prises les instances ont
fonctionné on a un conseil
d'administration on a des assemblées
générales on a des comités régaliens
dans lesquels sont représentés les
participes les représentants de la
Fédération Française de Rugby et ça ça a
continué finalement alors c'est vrai que
il y a eu un buzz un peu négatif sur le
rugby lié à ses affaires mais ça n'a pas
impacté la préparation de l'événement et
aujourd'hui moi je peux vous dire qu'on
est complètement en trajectoire on n'a
pas pris de retard tous nos indicateurs
sont ouverts on l'a dit la billetterie a
été vendue les sponsors sont là
l'engouement on vous a montré quelques
chiffres du public français et là et
finalement l'événement est tellement
fort que ces problèmes de gouvernance
comme le disait Julien n'ont pas impacté
l'événement parce que l'événement est
plus fort que que ce buzz médiatique et
finalement aujourd'hui on avance et on
n'a pas eu de retard sur ces sujets là
donc ça c'était pour les problèmes de
gouvernance qui sont un peu connexes à
côté de nous qui sont ceux de la
formation française de rugby après on a
eu nos propres problèmes de gouvernance
alors là quelques quelques éléments
factuels donc l'histoire a démarré avec
des articles de presse qui effectivement
ont souligné un management qui avait été
qualifié comme négatif pour ne pas
employer d'autres termes dans la foulée
de ces articles de presse la ministre
des Sports a immédiatement bien réagi en
diligentant deux choses
le premier c'est à saisir le comité
d'éthique du GIP donc ça c'est les
propres instances de gouvernance du GIP
qui ont fonctionné donc il y a eu un une
saisine par la ministre du comité
d'éthique et parallèlement il y a une
une saisine de l'inspection du travail
donc il y a eu deux missions qui ont été
lancées la première donc le comité
d'éthique donc présidé par un
hommagestra en retraite qui est Alain
Pichon qui a présidé la Cour des comptes
donc c'est quelqu'un un personnage qui
est une crédibilité affirmée dans et qui
fait autorité sur ces sujets là donc il
a il a produit un rapport du unité
d'éthique qui nous a été remis
exactement le 19 août et à la lecture de
ce rapport parce qu'en fait on ne
voulait pas uniquement prendre des
décisions basées sur des articles de
presse on voulait avoir des approches
objectifs de ce qui s'était passé donc
ce rapport de comité d'éthique a été
très très bien construit il y a eu 19
personnes et une centaine de personnes
dans le comité d'organisation donc il y
a eu 19 personnes qui ont été
auditionnées et donc à confirmé en fait
les articles de presse donc à la lecture
de ce rapport qui ont confirmé des
pratiques managériales alarmantes et
donc qui mettaient en danger la sécurité
et la santé des salariés donc nous avons
pris nos responsabilités au sein du
conseil d'administration et donc on a
mis à pied le directeur général donc ça
c'était la première étape donc la mise à
pied du directeur général qui a été
effectué le 29 août et c'était une mise
à pied à titre conservatoire dans
l'attente du rapport définitif de
l'inspection du travail et que nous
avons eu début octobre et qui a conduit
là à la deuxième étape
qui a consisté à ce qu'on licencie le
directeur général alors comme c'était un
contrat à durée déterminée la la formule
juridique a été la rupture anticipée de
son contrat de travail en fait c'est un
licenciement pour faute grave justifié
par ces deux rapports celui des comité
d'éthique et celui de l'inspection du
travail donc c'est une approche tout à
fait rationnelle qui a été faite et je
pense que c'est assez satisfaisant de
voir que ce sont les instances propres à
la gouvernance du GIP qui ont dans un
premier temps fonctionné au travers de
ce comité d'éthique puis après le
rapport de l'inspection du travail et
donc cette procédure a été tout à fait
conforme à la fois au droit du travail
et au droit également public puisque
nous sommes un groupement d'intérêt
public donc on a on a fait les choses
tout à fait dans l'ordre en toute
transparence et en toute on respect
parfait de la de la réglementation pour
produire donc cette décision qui a
consisté de façon unanime avec tous les
membres fondateurs il y avait la
Fédération française de rugby l'État et
bien sûr aussi wordre rugby qui a été
parti prenante dans le processus
décision donc qui nous a amené à
apprendre cette décision de changement
de la gouvernance et en miroir donc moi
on m'a j'ai donc été amené à proposer un
plan d'action suite au départ du
directeur général et donc ce qui a été
proposé ce que j'ai proposé au moment
fondateur c'est de mettre en place une
gouvernance collégiale donc avec un
président qui jusque-là était un
président tout à fait non exécutif et
très peu impliqué sur la conduite du
dossier moi j'avais pas de bureau
j'étais pas présent régulièrement dans
les instances de fonctionnement donc
d'un président plus opérationnel plus
plus présent dans le pilotage du du
comité d'organisation un directeur
général donc c'est Julien Colette et une
directrice générale adjointe Martine
nemeusek qui pilote plus
particulièrement l'organisation du
tournoi donc aujourd'hui on préside
cette gouvernance de façon collégiale
transparente et on a remobilisé en fait
tous les tous les acteurs toutes les
parties prenantes autour du projet et
encore une fois on n'a pas pris de
retard et on a complètement
mis en place tous les éléments
nécessaires à l'organisation success de
cet événement donc voilà ce que je
pourrais vous dire sur les sujets de
gouvernance peut-être un mot ce que vous
l'aviez mentionné aussi dans votre
introduction sur le résultat économique
de l'événement
Julien mentionné les dépenses il a
mentionné également les recettes au
final aujourd'hui après avoir fait un
travail en profondeur de revue
budgétaire là qu'on vient présenter
notre conseil d'administration il y a 15
jours on est capable d'affirmer qu'on va
sortir un résultat économique résultat
financier de l'événement qui sera entre
45 et 50 millions donc c'est un chiffre
très très bon puisque déjà dans le monde
des grands événements sportifs c'est pas
toujours évident d'avoir des grands
événements sportifs qui sont positifs
nous on sera nettement positif entre 45
et 50 millions d'euros et on a si on
peut le resituer par rapport à d'autres
événements comparables pour nous les
meilleures références c'est la Coupe du
Monde qui avait eu lieu en France en
2007 ou celle qui avait eu lieu en
Angleterre en 2015 et ces deux Coupes du
monde ont laissé autour de 36 36
millions d'euros de l'époque donc avec
un résultat autour de 45 à 50 millions
on peut dire qu'on aura une coupe du
monde qui sera très profitable et comme
vous le savez
ce résultat nous on n'a pas
d'actionnaires qu'on va rémunérer
l'actionnaire qu'on rémunère c'est le
rugby français puisque finalement le
résultat et ensuite redistribuer à
l'euro près au développement du sport en
France donc c'est le sujet de l'héritage
que vous avez mentionné aussi et donc
qui fera l'objet effectivement de d'une
politique de redistribution de ces 45 à
50 millions à l'ensemble du rugby du
rugby français voilà
peut-être là je passerai la parole à
Julien pour vous expliquer c'est un
process assez complexe qu'on a mis en
place sur la manière de redistribuer
l'héritage à la famille de rugby la
Fédération la ligue nationale de rugby
mais aussi les collectivités les villes
et les métropoles hautes qui ont été
partis prenantes dans dans l'opération
peut-être Julien tu peux détailler ça
oui merci Jacques effectivement pour
commencer à répondre
sur l'héritage les premièrement il faut
dire que le
bénéfice exploitation des opérations
d'organisation du tournoi va être
supérieur à 60 millions d'euros les 45
entre 45 et 50 millions d'euros dont
parle Jacques Rivoal sont le résultat
après prise en compte de campus 2023 de
l'économie de campus 2023 qui n'était
pas prévu par définition dans le dossier
de candidatures donc quand le dossier de
candidature affiché un résultat de 68
millions d'euros
évidemment sans anticiper les impacts de
l'inflation actuelle nous allons dégager
sur ce périmètre là plus de 60 millions
d'euros donc cet événement va être très
profitable et effectivement comme le
prévoit la convention constitutive et
l'intention de départ des membres
fondateurs la FFR et l'État la totalité
de de
l'héritage donc du de ce qu'on appelle
le bonus de liquidation du GIP mais ce
qui est qui au bénéfice d'exploitation
il y a au à des actions de développement
du rugby sur tout le territoire et non
pas des frais de fonctionnement de la
Fédération française de rugby ou de la
Ligue nationale de rugby ou de jeunes
c'est qui uniquement des actions de
développement du rugby dans ces actions
de développement du rugby 9 millions
sont déjà fléchés vers des aides à
l'emploi pour pérenniser 250 emplois
d'apprentis sachant que l'Agence
nationale du sport va débloquer la même
somme pour
aidé à la pérennisation de 250 autres
emplois d'apprentis campus 2023 par
ailleurs autour d'une quinzaine de
millions d'euros doivent être selon des
modalités qui sont en cours de
définition avec les services de l'État
doivent être dédiés à l'aide au centre
de formation des clubs pro les
comme vous le savez les clubs pro en
s'appuyant sur le réseau amateur et sur
la politique de formation de la
Fédération Française de Rugby
forme beaucoup de jeunes joueurs tous
les ans très talentueux qui constituent
une réserve pour le 15 de France qui
permet le succès du XV de France donc il
contribue à la performance du rugby
français de manière très forte
il permettent à des jeunes à des jeunes
passionnés de rugby de de faire valoir
leur performances dans des centres de
formation tout en poursuivant des études
dans le cadre d'un projet d'un double
projet et donc dans ce cadre là il est
important qu'être qu'au titre de
l'héritage un montant important soit
soit porté en soutien c'est de l'ordre
de 15 millions d'euros le solde va être
réparti entre les collectivités locales
à hauteur de 30% de 30% du montant pour
des projets d'investissement en lien
avec des clubs amateurs ou des organes
déconcentrés de la fédération
et au-delà de ces au-delà de ces 30% des
aides vont aller directement au club
amateurs pour des projets
qu'ils sont capables de développer
eux-mêmes sachant que et vous n'êtes
évidemment pas sans l'ignorer les clubs
amateurs sont très rarement propriétaire
des infrastructures des équipements
voire des matériels et donc ce sont les
collectivités particulièrement les
communes ou les ou les EPCI qui
porteront la plupart du temps ces
projets et qui bénéficieront en premier
lieu de ces aides mais pour bénéficier
de ces aides et devront y associer
obligatoirement ou un club ou un organe
un comité départemental de rugby ou une
ligue régionale de rugby
un comité héritage est en cours de
constitution et rendre un avis sur
chaque projet et chaque projet fera
aussi l'objet d'un avis préalable du
comité d'éthique avant que le conseil
d'administration l'approuve
terme de gouvernance aujourd'hui les
instances se réunissent tous les mois et
demi nous rendons compte
pouvoir exécutif rencontre devant le
Parlement du gypse tous les mois et demi
nous avons parlementarisé le
fonctionnement du zip et nous nous en
portons très bien
concernant
concernant le fait pour répondre aussi
au sénateur Savin le projet de faire
rester des équipes perdantes sur le
territoire jusqu'à la fin du tournoi
c'était une belle promesse
voilà nous mais qui n'avait pas été
malheureusement prise sans consulter ni
World rugby ni les fédérations
nationales et il se trouve que les
fédérations nationales dont sont
originaires ses équipes nous ont
expliqué que c'était quand même très
embêtant de garder en France des joueurs
qui devaient rejoindre des championnats
nationaux
au plus vite et donc nous nous n'avons
pas donné suite à cette proposition qui
par ailleurs n'était pas financée
concernant la billetterie
donc nous avons fait le choix
effectivement de créer une plateforme
officielle de revente qui est la seule
plateforme qui garantit aux détenteurs
de billets de pouvoir revendre leurs
billets
de manière
légale c'est à dire sans risque d'être
poursuivi pour cause de marché noir et
sans risque aussi d'acheter pour les
acheteurs d'acheter des billets qui
soient des des de vrais billets et pas
des billets manipulés ou des copies etc
etc cette plateforme de revente
elle n'autorise la revente qu'au prix
faciale de vendre du billet avec
l'application je l'ai dit d'une
participation au frais de l'ordre de 10%
donc ce qui n'évite pas le marché noir
puisqu'il y a la tentation de revendre
plus cher sur d'autres plateformes et
pour ça nous avons mis en place un
système de détection de suivi des
plateformes type diagogo qui ont
tendance
à donner de la place au marché noir et
nous les poursuivons en justice dès lors
que nous détectons des mouvements des
transactions anormales et nous avons
obtenu très récemment une décision de
justice favorable contre viagogo et nous
le ferons contre d'autres plateformes au
besoin
il faut souligner que de ce point de vue
la billetterie le fait qu'on maîtrise
l'habilletterie est essentiel et ça fera
le lien avec aux questions portant sur
la sécurité pour
garantir des conditions optimales de
sécurité à l'événement sur deux plans le
premier c'est qu'on maîtrise les données
clients on l'a dit ça permet à la fois
de méditer que des billets électroniques
et donc de ne pas avoir
de problématiques de contrôle de billets
imprimés de billets papier et ça permet
aussi de d'accroître la
cybersécurité de l'événement qui
aujourd'hui la menace majeure qui pèse
en fait sur sur l'organisation de
l'événement
nous travaillons de manière très étroite
avec le centre de renseignements
olympique qui a attaché à les cnsj et
les fonctionnaires de police du centre
de renseignement olympique ont
identifié comme menace principale le
risque cyber plus que les risques
d'attentats d'attaque terroristes ou de
délinquance donc ce risque là et
vraiment parmi nos priorités à traiter
nous travaillons de ce point de vue là
de manière très étroite avec l'ancie
nous avons nous faisons aussi appel un
prestataire spécialisé pour identifier
les failles éventuelles de sécurité dans
les gestion de nos systèmes
d'information
nous sachant que de ce point de vue là
le principal système d'information
qui mérite une attention particulière
c'est le système de contrôle des accès
au stade
catastrophes majeur ce serait que le
système de contrôle d'accès au stade
c'est fondre au juste avant un match
majeur donc nous concentrons nos efforts
sur les sécurisation de ce système et ce
qui nous aide c'est de maîtriser le
système de billetterie en amont et de
pouvoir communiquer de manière très
étroite avec les détenteurs de billets
donc des audits sont pilotés par Lanci
sur chacun de ces systèmes d'information
en particulier sur le contrôle d'accès
et
un
rattaché à notre centre principal des
opérations à l'état-major du tournoi
pendant le tournoi sera créé un centre
des opérations de sécurité notamment un
centre des opérations de sécurité si de
cybersécurité
donc ça permettra de suivre de suivre
ces sujets là de manière permanente en
veille permanente et nous sommes en
veille permanente sur cet aspect là en
matière de sécurité
alors effectivement il y a des quelques
groupes de supporters organiser mais ce
n'est pas quand même la culture du rugby
a un contrairement à celle du foot
donc de ce point de vue là un nous avons
quand même des relations avec les
fédérations nationales en particulier
les fédérations des îles britanniques
qui
dont vont être originaires beaucoup de
fans donc pour connaître leurs habitudes
etc etc nous savons aussi par le biais
de sondages auprès des détenteurs de
billets puisque nous détenons leur
donner que ceux-ci vont passer plusieurs
jours en France généralement famille ou
entre amis avec un budget conséquent
pour passer du temps
dans le pays profité de sa gastronomie
de son patrimoine et etc donc on va pas
être dans une logique de déplacement de
supporters
cibler sur une période très courte
avec l'idée de de uniquement de
fréquenter une rue de la soif un soir et
de repartir sans avoir forcément dormi
dans un hôtel là on est
notre public est constituée
de personnes
venant de l'étranger qui ont tous des
gens de l'hôtel qui ont un pouvoir
d'achat assez élevé qui ont prévu de
venir passer de séjourner en France de
manière assez durable donc ce qui nous
permet quand même de cibler les risques
de débordement avec le centre de
renseignements olympique de manière
assez fine et fiable et concernant le
public de supporters on est aussi
français on est aussi en lien évidemment
avec les clubs pro dans quasiment chaque
ville haute il y a des clubs pro de
rugby qui connaissent bien leur public
concernant la sécurité des villages de
rugby et des rues de la soif puisque je
crois que le sénateur Lauzac parlait de
ça
concernant la vraie où ça pardon
sénateur ça va pardon
la sécurisation
la sécurisation que nous sommes
enregistrés
la sécurisation des zones de célébration
effectivement de la responsabilité des
collectivités locales mais en lien avec
les forces de sécurité antérieure et
avec notre soutien en termes de conseils
naturellement dans le cadre de
coordination et de ce point de vue là
des comités de pilotage ont été mis en
place avec les préfectures dès le début
de l'année 2022 avec des groupes de
travail thématiques liés aux mobilité à
la sécurité des zones de célébration à
la sécurité des stades etc etc donc sur
chacun de ces sujets la coordination des
acteurs est très étroitement
assurés
ceci étant je pense que les
collectivités en l'occurrence sont un
débat avec l'État sur le coup de prise
en charge de la sécurité des Fan Zone et
le rôle des forces de sécurité
intérieure dans cette dans cette prise
en charge mais c'est assez c'est assez
classique et concernant
concernant les les zones de célébration
haute un les préfets sont très attentifs
à ce que
les villages de rugby soit les zones
principales de célébration et que le
maximum de fans puissent se réunir dans
ces zones qui sont plus faciles à
sécuriser que des zones disséminées
et donc aujourd'hui et c'est l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles sur le
territoire de la métropole européenne de
Lille on n'a pas encore de zone de
célébration
identifiées les préfets souhaitent
privilégier les zones de célébration
officielles ce qui n'interdit pas
évidemment aux fans de fréquenter de
fréquenter les bars etc etc et les
restaurants mais là en lien avec les
organisations professionnelles notamment
lui
on essaie de coordonner avec les
préfectures des dispositifs de sécurité
qui permettent de cibler d'identifier
les zones privilégiées de réunions
des fans de rugby voilà on les connaît à
Paris on les connaît ailleurs on les
connaît Toulouse etc etc donc elles sont
relativement bien identifiées mais c'est
vrai que là il peut y avoir il peut y
avoir un risque
peut-être pour terminer sur l'aspect
sécurité les appels d'offres sont en
cours la passation des appels d'offres
est en cours de finalisation vraiment
c'est une histoire de jour on a
identifié bien sûr quelques fragilités
n'est pas inquiet en général parce
qu'encore une fois le nombre d'agents de
sécurité qu'on cherche et leur
déploiement sont assez
usuels sur le marché de la sécurité
privée en France ceci étant ont même si
il n'y a que 20% des détenteurs de
billets qui seront des femmes on a un
sujet de mobilisation d'agents femmes
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas encore sûr
d'avoir le nombre d'agents femmes
suffisant pour contrôler les 20% de
détentrices de billets mais on y
travaille avec la filière avec les
filières locales avec le soutien de
l'État et des préfectures et du CNAPS en
particulier et tes antennes locales
et puis on a on a identifié
deux villes surtout de deux métropoles
ou
parce qu'il y a des spécificités locales
on aura besoin de prolonger l'appel
d'offres de gré à gré parce que
par exemple le FC Nantes a constitué un
service de sécurité interne qui lui
permet pas de répondre à nos appels
d'offres et donc aujourd'hui on doit
passer par d'autres biais pour avoir
pour travailler avec les sociétés de
sécurité mais c'est vraiment lié à un
contexte local voilà on espérant d'avoir
rien oublié monsieur pasidan si il y a
juste un point sur la participation de
du World rugby
la participation
collectivités locales pour répondre au
sénateur le Zac World rugby ne participe
pas financièrement puisque c'est nous
qui achetons des droits à World drugby à
hauteur
de 200 millions d'euros de droits
d'organisation enfin de 196 millions
d'euros exactement plus les droits liés
à l'organisation des prestations
d'hospitalité
qui sont de l'ordre de 90 millions
d'euros donc nous contribuions au
financement de rugby mondial à hauteur
de 280 millions d'euros
qui est derrière vertueux puisque c'est
280 millions d'euros vont principalement
aux fédération en développement et non
pas aux fédérations déjà professionnelle
premièrement
deuxièmement seul World rugby ce finance
avec 5 sponsors mais pas avec les autres
les autres sponsors nous financent nous
directement au tort de 80 millions
d'euros et enfin les collectivités
locales nous finance directement à
hauteur de 20 000 d'une vingtaine de
millions d'euros donc sur les 200
millions d'euros de dépenses
d'organisation strictes or les droits et
sur les
les 340 millions d'euros de recettes
enfin 440 millions de recettes pardon
donc c'est un montant
assez modeste mais qui ne prend pas en
compte la mise à disposition
d'installation notamment des camps de
base et des stades donc il y a un effort
plus élevé en réalité donc le soutien
des collectivités locales est important
et c'est pour ça que nous travaillons
avec elle de manière étroite sur
l'héritage pour qu'elle bénéficie
directement de retour en termes
d'héritage notamment bénéfice des clubs
qui sont sur leur territoire merci allez
je vais prendre toutes vos questions
vous demandant d'être assez synthétique
et en commençant par le supporter de
Brive pierre ouzouillas
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président je
dois vous le dire que j'ai été
particulièrement intéressé par votre
allocution parce que pour moi le rubis
c'est pas seulement un sport c'est un
art de vivre c'est une philosophie de la
vie donc vous nous parlez de célébration
pour moi c'est une cérémonie quasi
culturelle qu'il faut le réorganiser bon
je repasse en mode parisien monsieur le
Président vous m'excuserez pour pour
célébrer l'esprit rugby je voudrais dire
que c'est aussi l'esprit du Sénat parce
qu'ici
nous avons des affrontements parfois un
peu vif mais ne respectons les règles et
l'arbitre
nous respectons l'adversaire et nous
avons des troisième mi-temps donc il y a
il y a quelque chose de de proche entre
l'esprit rugby et l'esprit du Sénat moi
je voulais surtout vous féliciter parce
que vous avez
raffuté les assauts de mes collègues
mais moi je voulais vous vraiment vous
féliciter est très sincèrement
d'avoir mis cette composition cette
cette compétition sous l'esprit général
de la fraternité parce qu'un événement
sportif c'est d'abord ça c'est la
rencontre sur le terrain la rencontre à
l'extérieur du terrain de personnes qui
ont des cultures différentes mais qui
partagent un même enthousiasme et je
pense que c'est vraiment très fort de
d'avoir insisté je suis aussi très
content de de cette idée d'avoir mis en
place le rugby festival donc qui permet
de sortir du carcan un petit peu étroit
de l'organisation
très très
réglementé pour permettre une
participation plus large et très
sincèrement il faudrait que
vous mettiez à contribution les élus
pour que chacun dans leur territoire je
suis prêt à le faire dans les dans les
Hauts-de-Seine vous aide à initier
auprès des collectivités une une
relation qui permet justement de faire
vivre voilà alors je dis ça alors que
Brive va affronter la racine samedi que
ça va sans doute pas très bien se passer
merci monsieur le président
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur les présidents et directeurs
générales pour la présentation et les
réponses aux nombreuses questions qui
ont déjà été posées moi je voulais juste
peut-être revenir puisque je préside la
délégation droit des femmes au Sénat
revenir sur un joueur sur quatre
finalement qui est une femme et je
voulais d'abord savoir si cette
statistique était le fruit d'un travail
des instances du rugby et comment vous
expliquer également que finalement cette
cette montée en puissance des femmes
dans le sport du rugby ne se retrouvait
pas au niveau des spectateurs est-ce que
vous aviez au niveau de la billetterie
une politique finalement d'ouvrir sans
avoir la volonté finalement d'avoir des
offres qui s'adresseraient peut-être
plus à des familles plus à des femmes
est-ce que c'était ce résultat là
ensuite j'avais une question également
sur le modèle économique est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire si ce modèle économique
que vous nous avez présenté
qui repose essentiellement sur la
billetterie finalement est le même
modèle économique dans tous les grands
événements sportifs et puisque j'imagine
que non voilà
mon voisin d'en face souffle la réponse
donc peut-être qu'il pourra y répondre à
votre place monsieur le Président
et puis j'avais des questions sur
éventuellement on a vu il y a neuf sites
est-ce qu'il y a un ratio par rapport à
un nombre de d'événements pour les
matchs pour les sites pour les
spectateurs au niveau d'un équilibre
financier c'est-à-dire que vous avez
choisi 9 sites est-ce que c'est le
modèle économique qui fonctionne ou
est-ce que au-delà c'était en termes
d'équilibre financier c'était plus
compliqué à gérer et j'ai pu constater
dans votre présentation que sur les
sites il y avait une jauge qui était
très différente c'est à dire qu'on varie
quasiment du simple au double donc
est-ce que la sécurité demande en fait
multiplié par deux lorsqu'on parle du
simple au double ou multiplié par 3
comment vous gérez cette sécurité sur
des sites extrêmement différents et
également les capacités de transport
puisque nous sommes évidemment
lorsque vous êtes à Paris où vous êtes à
Nantes les capacités sont sont
différentes moi j'ai noté aussi que la
Bretagne était très absente de
du public c'est pas une carte de rugby
ok mais bon Nantes Nantes finalement
vous avez cité Nantes et la
Loire-Atlantique donc est-ce que vous
n'expliquez pas l'absence aussi par
l'absence de site sur lequel il va y
avoir des compétitions est-ce qu'il y a
un lien entre compétition et et
participation du public et puis
peut-être une question un peu plus
impertinente sur la Slade qui faisait
référence au jour de repos puisque en
2015 il y avait 331 jours de repos en
2023 il y en aura 441
donc comme on est dans une période où on
évoque beaucoup le travail actuellement
ben écoutez quid les joueurs sont-ils
fatigués en 2023
[Musique]
oui merci monsieur le Président je ne
vais pas me forcer à prendre l'accent du
Sud-Ouest
directeur pour pour répondre très très
précise et pour les informations que
vous avez données sur l'organisation de
la Coupe du Monde rugby je dirais à mes
collègues ça fait grand plaisir que l'on
parle de rugby parce qu'il y a dans
cette commission sorte de lobby de du
football qui nous a
imposé pendant des mois et des mois de
ne parler que de ballon ronds donc merci
de nous permettre de parler un petit peu
de ballon de ballon ovale ce matin
mon intervention je vous le dis tout de
suite ne signifie aucune nostalgie du
rubis cassoulet ni des 3e mi-temps ni de
la gestion de l'époque des parties
dessus de la Fédération française mais
mais malgré tout un peu je regardais
votre tableau tout à l'heure je suis élu
du premier département au nombre
d'achats de billets qui n'apprite pas
une métropole
et c'est un peu mes collègues opposés
des questions très techniques la mienne
sera peut-être un peu plus de l'ordre de
politique sur la politique de
déploiement et de développement du rugby
dans notre pays cependant parmi toutes
les questions techniques qui ont été
posées par notre rapporteur et par le
président du groupe sport du Sénat qui
est par Michel Server ils ont beaucoup
parlé de sécurité
ne conteste pas de la nécessité de
sécuriser la Coupe du monde j'ai bien
entendu ce que vous avez dit sur les
risques de
cyberata qui est sur l'inciter d'avoir
une cybersécurité tout cela ou le
partage moi j'ai beaucoup fréquenté de
match internationaux et nationaux
il est arrivé de parler avec les
policiers je peux vous dire qu'en
période de masse de rugby ils sont quand
même particulièrement décontractés et
plutôt des bonheurs donc il faut aussi
quand même rappeler ce qu'est le public
de rugby il y a pas plus beau public que
le public irlandais par exemple je peux
vous dire pour avoir été adjoint en
charge de l'espace public dans ma ville
de Biarritz alors demain dommage de
Coupe d'Europe d'Europe Dieu sait si les
brasseurs étaient heureux mais Dieu sait
aussi si l'adjoué en charge de l'espace
public était heureux et les pins
panneaux d'aussi de signalétique qui
était retourné c'est aussi ça le public
de rugby et je tenais moi qui est cher
Pierre le dire avec force
alors on vous souhaite bien sûr une
belle organisation on souhaite
éventuellement même si samedi le match a
montré qu'il y avait encore du travail
de beaux résultats pour l'équipe d'un
doigt Dupont vous avez montré la
dimension mondiale
de rugby vous avez aussi montré je vous
en remercie la dimension moderne du
rugby mais je voudrais poser une
question un peu d'ordre politique le
rugby que vous avez décrit
c'est un public qui c'est en rugby qui
devient mondial c'est un rugby qui entre
dans la modernité c'est un rugby qui
forme les talents comme on l'avait
répété qu'on vous l'avez rappelé cadeau
magnifique centre de performance et tout
ça c'est important
mais il y a une autre réalité du rugby
qui a été évoqué par Jean-Jacques le V
moins de licencier moins de clubs dans
une terre comme la mienne le Pays Basque
ou le Béarn on assiste à des fusions de
clubs parce que dans le rugby des
sous-préfectures et des chefs dieux de
cantons qu'on est aujourd'hui une
véritable hémorragie du nombre de
licenciés il y a un vieillissement du
public vous l'avez dit vous-même vous
l'avez avoué donc la question était
posée mais je voudrais vous titiller son
point vous la question vous avez été
posée sur les retombées de la Coupe du
monde de rugby sur le rugby amateur sur
les clubs amateurs sur le tissu sportif
sur ce la manière dont était construit
du rugby pour autant que regarde votre
vos cartes quand on regarde votre
déploiement bon on observe une chose
c'est qu'il est profondément
métropolitain alors je sais que le
business le rugby et les métropoles ça
fonctionne mais est-ce que vous ne
croyez pas qu'à terme on est en train de
scier la branche sur lequel on est assis
on est en train de se priver de ce tissu
de formation que constituer les clubs
amateurs des chefs-lieux de canton et
des petites communes est-ce qu'on n'est
pas en train de créer un écart entre le
rugby moderne que vous avez pas fait
tellement présenté et la réalité du
rugby amateur et les choix que vous avez
fait dans cette Coupe du monde de rugby
n'écarte-t-elle pas la réalité la Coupe
du Monde de la réalité de ce rugby avec
Harris avec un terme à risque de briser
de vivacité de priver quasiment de de
son nouveau le rugby dont vous avez par
ailleurs des clés l'entrée dans
modernité je vous remercie
non elle est bien riche je crois
Jacques gros Perrin
merci président et merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Directeur général
c'est vrai que moi j'ai beaucoup aimé le
mot célébré célébré étymologiquement
c'est fait des fêter un événement et
c'est vraiment un événement en tout cas
c'est 51 jours de fête que vous marquez
mais aussi de sport faut pas l'oublier
faut pas oublier également que c'est le
bicentaire de la création du rugby de ce
pasteur qui s'est déplacé lors d'un
match de foot avec un ballon et à la
main pour pouvoir marquer et c'est vrai
que cette bicentenaire ça peut être pas
être ci assez assez dit en tout cas et
on est loin historiquement en tout cas
de ce sport de voyou qui était pratiqué
par des gentlemen parce que les voyous
on s'est rendu compte qu'ils étaient pas
sur le terrain
en tout cas c'est cette immense
impatience nous l'avons et heureusement
parce que nous sommes fiers de en tout
cas de de cette équipe de France on a
été trois fois en finale mais on n'a
jamais gagné et je pense que ça aurait
du sens qu'on gagne cette fois-ci en
France alors moi j'ai deux questions la
première c'est vous nous avez fort bien
expliqué des choses et vous avez en tout
cas purgé beaucoup de choses et vous
avez bien fait de le faire vous n'avez
pas esquiver les questions parce qu'on
ne parlera plus des affaires après on
parlera simplement du rugby c'est une
bonne chose mais il y a une première
question c'est nous avait dit 20 nations
41 jours du 8 septembre au 21 octobre 51
jours pardon si on prend je veux pas
faire la comparaison avec les Coupes du
Monde de foot mais c'est parfois en tout
cas c'est souvent en plus de 30 nations
et c'est un mois alors moi je
m'interroge pourquoi autant de temps 51
jours avec moins de nations est-ce que
il y a des il y a des il y a des choses
je m'interroge pourquoi il faut beaucoup
plus de temps près de deux mois pour
pouvoir faire cette Coupe du Monde la
deuxième question peut-être bon je sais
pas la récupération parce que si on dit
ça les footballeurs vont être fâchés la
deuxième chose la deuxième chose c'est
votre prédécesseur en tout cas en 2017
même si avait parlé de bénéfices pour la
France autour du 200 millions vous avez
bien expliqué les choses en 2022 c'était
95 et à pied après le conseil
d'administration du GIP c'est 68
millions d'euros qui a été redescendu à
40 pour le journal L'Équipe c'était 40
millions d'euros pour vous aujourd'hui
on a entendu c'était 45 millions qu'ils
sont les éléments en tout cas quels sont
les méthodes utilisées pour chiffrer
cela parce que c'est quelque chose aussi
qui qui peut nous interpeller d'autant
que l'Inspection générale des finances
elle est plus prudente prudente et elle
dit que quitte à mobilisé une partie du
bénéfice en tout cas il faudrait
peut-être surtout en garantir la
réalisation et je crois que c'est pas
ton ça qui est primordial pour nous en
tout cas vous vous avez cette logique
économique et on l'entend bien mais ce
qui est primordial pour nous c'est cette
belle fête qui soit en tout cas et qui
déprime je vous remercie Bernard
oui merci monsieur le Président moi je
voudrais juste faire une petite
correction sur votre introduction la
Coupe du monde de rugby c'est pas une
répétition ni même un brouillon des Jeux
Olympiques ça sera plutôt un exemple je
pense compte tenu des valeurs du du
rugby moi j'ai bien apprécié les
retombées géographiques avec la
répartition sur sur l'ensemble du
territoire il y a une deuxième
répartition géographique qui est plus
plus micro c'est celle qu'on sait que le
rugby max prison l'a dit c'est un
recrutement rural pour
un sport d'élite
métropolitain dans les grandes villes
compte tenu de l'économie il y a quand
même une partie un peu du territoire qui
est moins concernée qu'on arrive moins à
pénétrer c'est celui des banlieues alors
certes il y a des beaux exemples comme
ce que fait le club de Massy par exemple
mais il y a un vrai travail est-ce qu'il
y a un travail spécifique qui va être
fait justement pour sensibil iser
des populations qui sont pas forcément
très à culturer par les valeurs du rugby
et ça je pense que c'est quelque chose
d'important
moi j'ai bien entendu
rassuré sur les problèmes de billetterie
et de revente parce que lorsqu'on vend
beaucoup de billets très à l'avance on
pouvait être inquiets sur le problème de
la revente des billets après il reste
deux choses pour moi c'est un risque et
un fléau ça va comment vous y êtes là le
risque c'est le sport est le rugby est
un sport on dit viril mais correct mais
qui malgré tout est quand même de plus
en plus violent et une des raisons
d'ailleurs un peu qui était analysée de
la désaffection un peu pour du rugby
c'est
lorsqu'on voit les les chocs et les
traumatismes qui peuvent être subis
quels sont le fait qu'on souhaite pas
que les enfants aillent pratiquer un
haut niveau ce sport et ce qui serait
dramatique pour pour cette coupe du
monde si c'est une réussite sportive
c'est qui est par exemple des
traumatismes qui marquent un peu avec
des joueurs qui gardent des séquelles et
je pense que là bénéfices qu'on pourrait
retirer de cet événement pourrait tomber
à l'eau deuxième chose c'est le fléau du
dopage qui maintenant touche tous les
sports et savoir s'il y a des choses
particulières qui vont être faites
comment ça va être traité pendant cette
coupe du monde voilà en vrai pour
rassurer notre collègue billon Annick
Billon et sur les propos de Max Brisson
le rugby c'est un sport de voyou
pratiqué par des gentlemans qui savent
les hommes savent aussi acheter des
places pour les femmes pour qu'elles
puissent venir assister au match
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
chez moi de vouloir intervenir merci
messieurs pour vos informations et vos
réponses très complètes effectivement on
est très heureux d'accueillir la Coupe
du monde de rugby notamment à Lyon
puisqu'on accueille les All Blacks qui
ont notamment avec leur parcours avoir
le temps de visiter Lyon et même le
Beaujolais je pense
vu leur parcours moi je voulais revenir
sur la sécurité puisque ça nous a
beaucoup occupé dans la Commission au
moment du fiasco du Stade de France et
la finale de la Ligue des Champions et
sorti cette semaine un rapport de l'UEFA
qui
grosso modo reprend beaucoup de nos
analyses nous au Sénat qui cite
d'ailleurs notre rapport
et parmi les recommandations ou parmi ce
qui était pointé le mauvais dialogue
entre les autorités et les supporters
le manque d'information entre les deux
et notamment au moment où il a fallu
réorganiser un peu le enfin agir pour
maintenir l'ordre et l'utilisation des
gaz lacrymogènes qui a provoqué
l'incompréhension de la grand nombre de
supporters anglais et l'UEFA pointe un
là un déficit de dialogue entre les
autorités et les supporters est-ce que
c'est une recommandation que vous avez
est-ce que vous avez déjà vous avez
intégré un certain nombre de choses qui
ont été dites dans ce rapport ou dans le
rapport du Sénat et est-ce que
ce dialogue puisque vous l'avez montré
la moitié du public est internationale
est-ce que ce dialogue entre les
spectateurs et les forces de l'ordre et
est-ce que la question du maintien de
l'ordre et de la doctrine de maintien de
l'ordre est actuellement en discussion
voilà
Claude Kern
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur général beaucoup
de questions déjà été posées donc je
vais être très bref je vais pas rajouter
cette liste Prévert mais juste
je dirais vous remercier vous féliciter
d'avoir
tenu compte du rapport de nos deux
commissions respectives la commission
des lois et de la commission de la
culture en ce qui concerne les
événements sur venus au Stade de France
en mettant en place cette fameuse
billetterie nominative
dématérialiser et infalctifiable donc
merci à vous parce que nous nous l'avons
repris au niveau du projet de loi Jeux
Olympiques
de la commission sur le projet de joie
et c'est effectivement l'amendement qui
nous a proposé genre
merci président rassurez-vous je
laisserai les évocations caricaturales
de mes collègues max et Jacques impuni
pour le moment
pour ne pas engager une polémique mais
merci pour vos informations messieurs
moi il se trouve que par amour profond
d'un sport qui se joue avec un ballon
qui ne rebondit pas dans tous les sens
je parcours l'Europe
et dans des très grands stades
partout je suis accueilli sans problème
des flux de 70 à 80 000 supporters ils
sont chaque semaine accueillies sans
aucun problème dernièrement encore au
stade San Siron de Milan pour assister
au derby de l'amadonina entre deux clubs
qui se détestent des supporters qui se
détestent sans aucun problème et ça
c'est toutes les semaines
dès qu'on organise un événement sportif
de cette taille en plus dans notre beau
pays on a toujours l'impression que ce
sont les douze travaux d'Hercule ma
question est simple je voulais savoir si
le GIP est en relation avec justement
ces organisations qu'il s'agisse de
football il y a 38 millions de
licenciés au monde je le rappelle est-ce
qu'on est est-ce que vous êtes en
rapport avec ces gens qui savent faire
depuis des lustres dans des stades bien
plus grands que les nôtres organiser ces
événements est-ce qu'il y a des rapports
techniques
entre ces instances et les vôtres David
Assouline
oui moi aussi je veux remercier nos deux
intervenants de ce matin qui qui nous
ont donné
de façon assez précise quand même
comment les choses vont se passer et
comment elles ont été organisées merci
beaucoup pour ça
beaucoup ont présenté cette coupe du
monde et en général les Coupes du Monde
de rugby avant les JO un an avant que
Tokyo c'était pareil bon comme une
espèce de répétition générale d'un
moment qui va être encore plus grand
plus intense
d'accueil bon on voit bien que les
problématiques et vous ne l'avez bien
fait remarquer sont un peu différentes
d'abord tout ce que le nom on a pu
constater de difficultés
parce que ça percutait les festivals les
festivals culturels etc c'est hors
période estivale ensuite il y a pas une
concentration de 80% de ce qui va se
passer à Paris et Seine-Saint-Denis
bon donc les problématiques et de
sécurité de flux de transport etc sont
sont assez différents même si il y aura
des aspects comme ça oui d'accord de
millions de personnes qui peuvent être
similaires aussi l'étalement dans le
temps
je trouve très bien je sais pas qui il a
décidé comment etc mais le fait que ça
dure deux mois pour faire que chaque
athlète et 5 jours de récupération c'est
enfin
considérer que le spectacle la
performance c'est bien mais ça peut pas
être au détriment des corps des athlètes
et cette façon de chercher toujours la
performance peut atteindre à la santé
des athlètes et on le voit beaucoup en
plein domaine du sport et à un moment
donné c'est l'humain qui doit reprendre
sa place et même si ça prolonge
quand même de façon importante
la compétition
après il y a des questions il y a une
question vous ne répondez pas alors
peut-être parce que il y a enquête etc
mais et le président Lafond et mon ami
lausaac où nous ont posé la question
même s'il y a pas d'impact
sur la vente des billets sur l'image de
la compétition que vous êtes en charge
l'organisée la crise
le gouvernance de la fédération de rugby
française et de
votre organisation est quand même
on aimerait que vous vouliez votre point
de vue
pourquoi qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
pour que ça ne se reproduise pas etc
donc
dites nous si vous voulez ne pas
répondre mais ne faites pas comme si la
question n'a pas été posée
moi je suis pour qu'on célèbre les
fraternités entre le rugby et le
football et donc qu'on exagère pas les
choses parce que on a parlé de des
supporters et irlandais quand il s'agit
de rugby ils peuvent boire beaucoup de
bières mais ils sont charmants je peux
vous dire qu'au football c'est pareil
j'étais
à l'Euro 2016 je me suis retrouvé à Lyon
justement où l'Irlande jouait contre la
France dans les tramways dans les
transports avec eux c'était incroyable
il chantait même du Edith Piaf
et non mais c'est
on sait que les supporters les
supporters irlandais c'est pas ceux qui
créent il faudrait faire attention à pas
considérer que
c'est le public qui crée des problèmes
seulement parce que c'est pas du tout ce
qui nous a été dit par le rapport le
rapport qui est sorti hier dit que
d'abord c'est l'UEFA et ensuite c'est le
ministère intérieur et les autorités
compétentes préfectures etc et ne dit
pas que les supporters de football qui
ont été exemplaires et c'est grâce à eux
que ça pas plus dégénéré et ceux de
Liverpool en particulier qui sont
souvent été mis comme les hooligans du
football en Europe donc il y a pas le
bon public
celui du rugby et celui qui a un peu
trop populaire des quartiers et des
banlieues qui seraient celui du foot
mais c'est c'est pas aussi caricatural
même si l'ambiance est bonne dans le
rugby voilà donc ma question c'est
[Musique]
celle sur la gouvernance et
que vous nous en disiez un peu plus
dernière intervention rapide de Michel
Savard premier président rapidement ce
que tout à l'heure le président évoqué
les conditions de rupture de contrat de
l'ancien directeur général notamment sur
des motifs sur du harcèlement moral ma
seule question y a-t-il eu des plaintes
du personnel
ici on vous laisse répondre alors
peut-être d'abord moi je reviendrai sur
les deux mots que vous avez cités la la
célébration et les fraternités les
fraternité parce que je pense
qu'effectivement ce sont des mots très
très forts la célébration c'est la fête
et la fraternité c'est effectivement
c'est pas uniquement parce que c'est un
mot qui est inscrit à au fronton de nos
écoles et de nos établissements publics
mais c'est un mot très très fort très
riche et je crois que ça colle
parfaitement à ce que représente le
rugby et je pense que et c'est aussi ce
qu'on essaye de faire avec cette coupe
du monde c'est que finalement c'est ça
ça match parfaitement avec les valeurs
du rugby et avec ce que peut représenter
une coupe du monde pour les
problématiques actuelles de la société
donc nous on a été amené à réfléchir
comme comme toute entreprise finalement
au sens à la mission à la raison d'être
d'une organisation comme celle de du
comité d'organisation d'une coupe du
monde comme le font maintenant les
entreprises et finalement on se dit
voilà on peut modestement parce que faut
pas non plus
survaloriser ce qu'on peut faire mais je
pense qu'on peut avec une coupe du monde
adressée en quelque sorte les
problématiques actuelles de la société
donc c'est ce plan RSE qu'on vous a
montré là avec des thèmes qui sont très
très structurants
l'économie durable et circulaire la
formation l'éducation l'emploi
l'environnement l'inclusion voilà c'est
des sujets qui sont des sujets actuels
de la société et si on résume ça avec ce
Clem ou ce un peu ce slogan qui va nous
guider maintenant jusqu'à jusqu'à la
Coupe du Monde un célébrons toutes les
fraternités c'est ça parce que moi je
pense fondamentalement que le rugby est
moderne aujourd'hui et correspond
exactement aux problématiques actuelles
de la société une société qui est
fragmentée une société qui est
archipelisée segmentée où les gens se
referment sur eux-mêmes le rugby ça
attend du lien social le rugby avant
tout c'est le respect c'est le collectif
c'est l'engagement et ça c'est actuel et
c'est ce qu'on veut mettre en avant avec
cette coupe du monde et ça rejoint ce
que disait madame la sénatrice qui nous
a quitté maintenant c'est aussi ça je
crois qui fait que aujourd'hui le nombre
de licenciés dans le rugby augmente que
les femmes une jeune fille viennent au
rugby parce qu'elles se retrouvent dans
les valeurs du rugby que les familles
viennent aujourd'hui acheter des billets
veulent aller voir des matchs de rugby
parce qu'on sait que un match de rugby
ça se passera bien et c'est la
fraternité la fraternité entre les
supporters la fraternité entre les
équipes dans un match de rugby l'équipe
perdante attend religieusement ou de
façon très respectueuse que l'équipe
gagnante est fait le tour des supporters
pour les saluer et font un une raie
d'honneur pour accueillir les les
perdants et les saluer lorsque les
Français avaient battu les Néo-Zélandais
à l'automne les All Blacks
respectueusement des très modestement
ont attendu que les Français aient fini
leur tour de leur tour du stade pour les
saluer c'est ça le rugby on trouve pas
ça dans les autres sports et moi j'ai
été j'ai été un ancien joueur de rugby
je suis encore maintenant éducateur dans
un petit club de rugby j'entraîne des
tout petits enfants qui ont 5 ans et 6
ans je suis très content de continuer à
faire ça parce que je suis un président
bénévole donc j'ai encore un peu de
temps pour faire ça et donc quand je
demande aux parents pourquoi vous amenez
vos enfants au rugby alors 50% c'est
parce que le grand-père le père l'oncle
a joué au rugby mais d'autres non c'est
pas pour cette raison là c'est tout
simplement pour les vertus éducatives du
rugby et ça c'est très fort je trouve
les parents vous disent ça aujourd'hui
le rugby ça a des valeurs éducatives et
je pense que c'est ça modestement qu'on
peut faire avec avec cette belle coupe
du monde et célébrer les fraternités
c'est tout ça qu'on va faire donc on est
on est très content que vous adhériez à
ce moto donc ça c'était à l'aspect
positif alors pour revenir sur votre
question parce que vous y revenez sur la
sur la gouvernance bon effectivement on
reste un peu pudique sur ces sujets là
pour des raisons évidentes écoutez nous
on n'a pas de légitimité à à s'exprimer
sur les problèmes de gouvernance de la
de la Fédération française de rugby
peut-être que modestement moi avec mon
regard de de chef d'entreprise ou de
venant du monde de l'entreprise
peut-être que le mouvement sportif a
besoin effectivement de de d'évoluer au
niveau de sa gouvernance c'est un peu ce
qu'on ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui on
voit bien que par rapport au monde de
l'entreprise il y a sûrement encore un
des sujets sur lequel il faut que le le
monde sportif évolue je pense que des
profils comme le mien des profils comme
comme Julien Colette sont peut-être
adaptés effectivement aux problématiques
actuelles de la gouvernance des du monde
du monde sportif
après
je pense qu'en miroir pour revenir au
problème de gouvernance qui sont
spécifiques au GIP vous comprendrez que
en miroir l'organisation ou la
gouvernance qu'on a mis actuellement en
place
a pour but de répondre aux
dysfonctionnements qu'on a connu dans le
passé pour rester pudique si on a assez
si j'ai proposé moi une gouvernance
collégiale collective transparente qui
vise à associer tout le monde c'est bien
pour répondre effectivement ce qui avait
peut-être dysfonctionné dans le passé
voilà donc pour rester encore une fois
pudique sur ces sujets là parce que j'ai
pas envie de revenir sur ces sujets qui
ont été douloureux pour pour les
événements pour pour l'événement et
surtout pour les collaborateurs parce
que qui ont souffert de cette période
difficile voilà voilà ce que je peux
vous dire de façon positive sur ces
sujets là et je crois qu'aujourd'hui on
a mis en place une gouvernance qui est
adaptée qui est moderne et qui est
adapté à la à la sophistication que
représente le pilotage d'un d'un grand
événement sportif comme celui-là parce
que moi venant encore une fois du monde
de l'entreprise je considère
qu'aujourd'hui un GIP un comité
d'organisation c'est une entreprise mais
une entreprise éphémère de par sa
définition mais qui est beaucoup plus
complexe qu'une entreprise parce que le
nombre de parties prenantes qu'il faut
fédérer autour du projet et très très
important entre les sponsors les villes
hautes les collectivités territoriales
l'état wordre rugby la Fédération
française de rugby voilà la mission de
notre collègue de notre comité
d'organisation c'est d'arriver à fédérer
tout ce monde-là autour de l'événement
et c'est assez complexe et ça nécessite
une gouvernance et un management
probablement plus sophistiqué que ce
qu'on avait pu faire dans le passé ce
qu'on essaye de faire modestement
aujourd'hui
voilà après peut-être je laisserai
Julien répondre aux autres sujets
peut-être pour rebondir sur ce que
disait
sénateur de la Corrèze on va mettre à
l'honneur le territoire parisien puisque
on participe à la coproduction d'un film
qui va bientôt sortir qui s'appelle port
l'honneur qui va montrer les vertus
éducatives du rugby et le hasard fait
qu'il se passe en Corrèze voilà donc je
fais un peu de publicité mais je pense
que c'est important parce que ça mettra
en valeur les valeurs éducatives du
rugby et ses vertus là ses collègues
j'interroge juste une seconde il est
sénateur des Hauts-de-Seine
j'étais pris par son accent et des navré
je comprends mieux pourquoi vous vous
supporterez les deux équipes lors du
prochain match je comprends bien
concernant le modèle économique et la
sécurité le fait de choisir des stades
dans des métropoles premièrement si nous
avions fait un choix purement économique
nous n'aurions organisé les matchs qu'au
stade de France à Marseille alors c'est
vrai que les phases finales ne se passe
qu'au stade de France à Marseille mais
le but c'est de réunir quand même
au-delà de l'aspect économique le
maximum de fans et aujourd'hui les deux
stades qui dépassent les 60 000
spectateurs
et qui sont modernes adaptés et
d'ailleurs le vélodrome encore plus que
le Stade de France de part sa rénovation
à sonde ce sont les stades que je viens
de citer pour le reste nous avons quand
même
choisi d'organiser des matchs dans 9
villes hautes dans 9 stade haute au
total dans des terres qui sont de rugby
et des terres qui ne sont pas de rugby
et dans des stades qui n'ont pas
forcément été modernisés récemment nous
aurions pu aussi ne choisir que les
stades issus de l'Euro 2016 ça n'a pas
été le cas nous avons choisi des stades
qui posent question qui ont posé
question à World rugby qui ont posé
question aux autorités sportives
nationales et internationales pour
permettre aux supporters de toute la
France de venir voir des matchs puisque
aujourd'hui 80% des Français vivent à
moins de deux heures de route d'un stade
donc c'était un choix important et qui
n'est pas qui qui a un choix de
compromis mais on doit faire des
compromis dans l'organisation d'un grand
événement entre le fait pouvoir
permettre au maximum de spectateurs de
regarder les matchs
à proximité de leur domicile ceci étant
nous n'avons pas écarté les territoires
encore une fois cette Coupe du Monde et
celle des territoires puisque les camps
de base sont répartis sur quasiment tout
le territoire alors il est vrai que le
grand est le grand oubliés pour plein de
raisons est lié à la faiblesse de la
présence du rugby dans le Grand Est mais
la Bretagne ne l'est pas l'équipe
chilienne sera en grande base à
Perros-Guirec le club de le RC vannes
participent de manière active à
l'animation du territoire la Bretagne va
accueillir la Coupe du monde de rugby
militaire
il sera soutenu dans ce sens par les
autorités du rugby
donc il y a un effort très important qui
est fait dans ce sens et si cet effort
d'ailleurs qui guide la recherche d'un
bénéfice non pas pour assurer la
rentabilité économique de l'événement ça
n'aurait aucun sens nous sommes
délégataires d'une mission d'intérêt
général une mission de service public
c'est pour
dégager
des enveloppes qui vont permettre de
financer des investissements en faveur
du développement du rugby sur tout le
territoire et l'équilibre que nous avons
cherché dans la revue budgétaire récente
c'est un équilibre entre assurer
l'excellence de l'organisation de
l'événement avec tout ce que ça implique
en termes de sécurité en termes de
qualité de l'expérience spectateur et
donc
de conformité au standard internationaux
que vous citiez très justement monsieur
le sénateur parce qu'on a tendance dans
ce pays à chaque fois qu'on organise un
match un événement ou quoi que ce soit
d'autre à réinventer la poudre à ne pas
se comparer à ce que font les autres
alors que vous le disiez très justement
les Italiens dans le foot et dans le
rugby d'ailleurs sont de plus en plus
sont très performants et savent
parfaitement faire les choses et qu'on a
pas besoin de leur donner des leçons
mais c'est un point de vue personnel que
je me permets d'exprimer parce que je
pense qu'il est important
il est important et donc on est
aujourd'hui dans une stratégie très
forte de coopération avec les autres
acteurs nous ne ce n'est pas parce que
nous travaillons de manière très étroite
avec worldogbe que nous sommes les
vallées des Anglais
je ne suis pas d'où vient cette rumeur
dans certains dans certaines parties du
rugby je pense que nous avons tout à
nous honorer de travailler de manière
très étroite avec tous les
professionnels du secteur qui sont qui
essaient d'organiser au mieux des grands
événements et de valoriser au mieux ce
sport partout dans le monde et les
bénéfices aussi de cette coupe du monde
vont profiter à d'autres nations de
rugby
voilà ce que je voulais dire sur cet
aspect là parce qu'il est important et
cet équilibre là il n'est pas facile à
trouver et il est c'est pour ça que nous
rendons régulièrement compte à nos
instances et dans notre conseil
d'administration siège avait fait faire
l'état de CNOSF avec voix des
libératives mais sièges beaucoup de
personnalités qualifiées avec voix
consultatives
dont les représentants des collectivités
locales et c'est important pour nous de
bénéficier de leur retour et nous sommes
aussi en lien permanent avec les clubs
amateurs sans doute insuffisamment mais
en tout cas c'est une réalité
que qu'il ne faut pas qu'il ne faut pas
cacher
au-delà des
territoires ADN en rugby qui sont
effectivement on ne peut pas les oublier
ils sont au coeur de notre stratégie
effectivement il faut intéresser aussi
les jeunes des banlieues des grandes
villes à ce sport et de ce point de vue
là non seulement nous sommes en relation
avec des collectivités comme le
département de la Seine-Saint-Denis et
la ville de Saint-Denis nous allons
visiter encore ce soir pour mettre en
valeur leurs zones de célébration mais
nous allons aussi lancer un tournoi
national des quartiers qui dans les
quartiers des grandes villes par exemple
avec le soutien de la métropole de Lyon
va permettre d'organiser au pied des des
tours de constituer des équipes avec des
jeunes au pied des tours qui ne
connaissent pas le rugby et les équipes
gagnantes iront jouer à Marcoussis la
finale pendant la Coupe du Monde
c'est une petite pierre l'édifice pas
suffisante mais aujourd'hui en équipe de
France il y a de plus en plus de jeunes
issus de ces territoires qui sont aussi
des des exemples et qu'on cherche à
valoriser à valoriser au mieux et de
plus en plus
je vais sans doute oublié des choses
pour ne pas me perdre concernant les
dispositifs de sécurité pour y revenir
effectivement
on cherche à encore une fois à coopérer
avec tous les acteurs encore une fois
les supporters ne sont pas forcément
organisés comme ceux de foot
c'est d'ailleurs peut-être un exemple à
suivre dans dans le rugby donc nous
travaillons plutôt avec les acteurs
institutionnalisés que sont les
fédérations on essaie aussi de
s'inspirer des pratiques qui sont mises
en place à l'occasion des championnats
et encore une fois on s'est organisé
aussi des matchs en France un des matchs
importants de Ligue 1 de Top 14 l'Euro
2016 c'est plutôt bien passé je crois
donc on a cette expérience là
analyser la menace de manière très fine
et puis à mobiliser des volontaires qui
viennent du rugby qui viennent de tous
les territoires de rugby 4500
volontaires vont
sur une réserve de 7000 d'ailleurs mais
4500 ont été sélectionnés vont être
mobilisés sur tous les territoires
et en complément les collectivités les
villes et les métropoles hautes vont
elles aussi mobiliser des volontaires
qui seront au contact direct avec les
spectateurs donc des passionnés de rugby
vont être en contact direct avec
d'autres passionnés de rugby pour les
aider à trouver leur chemin à aller vers
la bonne Fan Zone à trouver le bon accès
au stade etc etc
évidemment en relation étroite avec les
services de sécurité avec les forces de
sécurité intérieure
[Musique]
et de ce point de vue là nous avons
adapté les dispositifs effectivement de
sécurité en fonction de la taille et de
la jauge des stades nous mobilisons
jusqu'à 1000 agents de sécurité autour
du Stade de France pour 300 à la
Beaujoire
sécurité donc il y avait sécurité des
joueurs on a pris deux décisions c'est
ça a été mentionné tout à l'heure c'est
qu'on a on a on a prolongé le la durée
de la compétition qui était de 45 jours
initialement on est passé maintenant à
51 jours tout simplement pour qui est
pour toutes les équipes ce qui était pas
le cas avant dans le format à 45 jours
une période de 5 jours de repos entre
tous les matchs avant c'était pas le cas
il y avait des équipes qui jouaient à
moins de cinq jours donc c'était pas bon
pour la contrairement au foot le rugby
est un sport de de d'engagement de
combat collectifs et il faut récupérer
entre deux matchs donc 5 jours c'est
fait pour protéger la santé la sécurité
des joueurs et en plus on a augmenté
également le nombre de joueurs
participants avant c'était 31 maintenant
c'est passé à 33 donc il y a 33 joueurs
donc là aussi pour pour protéger la
santé des des joueurs et puis l'autre
sujet à l'autre la dernière question que
vous posez c'est sur le dopage aussi
donc on travaille bien sûr avec World
rugby parce que c'est un sujet
fédération international et avec
l'Agence Française sur la lutte contre
le dopage bien sûr sur ces sujets là il
y aura des protocoles spécifiques et
puis on organisera pendant la
compétition ou c'est pas si c'est la
troisième ou la quatrième mais on
organisera une opération spécifique sur
sur le dopage sur la promotion la lutte
contre le dopage pendant pendant les
événements pour sensibiliser à ce sujet
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
là-dessus
juste le dernier point de Michel Savas
sur les plaintes ce qui a eu des
plaintes déposées par oui alors en fait
plainte en fait encore une fois on a
fait une navigation une investigation
par le comité d'éthique il y a eu 19
témoignages ensuite il y a une
inspection du travail qui a auditionné
plus de 60 personnes on a eu ensuite en
fait un autre rapport en cette missionné
par notre CSE qui lui a donc
l'inspection du travail c'était un
rapport de 60 pages le rapport du CSA
par un cabinet extérieur sur le social
c'était un rapport de 120 pages il a il
a auditionné 50% du personnel donc on
est à sur 200 personnes il y a 100
personnes 100 personnes c'est énorme
quoi terme de témoignages et
effectivement toutes ces alors après on
a eu aussi un rapport de l'Inspection
générale des finances donc à la fin on a
eu quatre rapports sur le sujet du
climat social et aussi des sur des
sujets de probité et tous les
témoignages sont concordants à 99,9%
tous les témoignages ont confirmé que il
y avait des pratiques tout à fait
inadmissibles en termes en termes de
management voilà
pas de plainte au sens juridique du
terme pénal du terme mais des auditions
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général merci beaucoup pour
toutes ces précisions que vous n'avez
apportées je crois que c'était très
important de vous entendre et vous
entendre justement dans une dynamique
positive de préparation de cet événement
auquel on est les au sein de ces
commissions très attachées qu'on est un
lien proche ou distant avec le rugby
nous sommes tout à fait conscient que la
Coupe du monde de rugby sera un
événement important pour notre pays et
c'est pour ça qu'on voulait vous
entendre et bien sûr vous manifestez à
travers cette audition aussi notre
soutien dans votre travail de
préparation qu'on imagine intense
jusqu'au début du mois de septembre et
même pendant le mois de septembre
pendant toute la Coupe du monde de rugby
merci beaucoup
[Musique]